Bueno pues buenas tardes, buenas tardes a todos, soy Sergi Sánchez de Celsan Sistemas.
Empezamos el séptimo webinar de TrayStation en directo desde bolsa.com, bueno estamos
aquí en MSL, en las oficinas MSL en Madrid, pero lo estamos retransmitiendo también para
todos los internautas de bolsa.com, vale, bueno, a ver, vamos a, a ver un momentito
que me oigo doble, vale, gracias, venga, voy a compartir la pantalla, bueno, voy bastante
por directo porque tenemos bastantes cosas a comentar hoy, se ve bien, sí, se ve bastante
bien, verdad, aquí en internet confío que también, voy a ver un momentito, supongo
que también, vale, bueno, a ver, antes un breve repaso a un poquito, lo muy breve,
porque va completamente ligado a lo que vamos a hacer ahora en el 7, pero brevemente lo
que comentamos en el 6 que era la iniciación de los sistemas para aquellos que no asistierais,
el disclaimer que es importantísimo, ya os lo habéis leído todos, ya lo sabéis de memoria,
bueno ya sabéis también lo que es TrayStation y los que no lo sabéis pues os recomiendo
que entréis en nuestra web, celsanstistemas.com y encontraréis mucha información al respecto
o sino también en la web de TrayStation, por supuesto, aunque más bien en inglés,
TrayStation es una plataforma, software y en este caso que vamos a tratar hoy para
backtesting y operativa con sistemas, vale, lo bueno es que te permite, te permite testearlo,
te permite crearlo y te permite también operarlo, vale, es en ese sentido una solución global
porque pues también es broker, de acuerdo, por lo tanto eso en mi opinión es una ventaja
bastante notable, una plataforma muy premiada, me lo paso porque ya sé que lo habéis visto
en anteriores webinars, vale, bueno, voy a ir a las cosas un poquito que me interesan
con relación a webinar 7, no vamos a repasarlo todo el 6, ya sabéis que están todos disponibles
tanto en bolsa.com como en nuestra web, en las secciones celsanstistemas, media y formación
si no recuerdo mal, allí están todos los vídeos publicados, tanto este como el 6 y
los anteriores webinars los podéis consultar allí, vale, el tema de los datos históricos
y el backtesting, vamos a continuar a partir un poco de aquí, vamos a ver lo que es una
optimización de ciertas maneras de optimizar, vamos a ver una solución para trabajar con
nuestras carteras de sistemas, vale, pero es importantísimo comentar antes el tema
del backtesting básico, de acuerdo, dijimos que una muy buena manera de comenzar era con
los elementos precreados, voy a ir cambiando un poquito la plataforma, siempre cuando pueda
hacerlo, claro, así va a ser mejor, de los elementos precreados, aquellos que no tengáis
nociones de programación y que no sepáis nada de easy language, que es el lenguaje
de programación de 3D Station, que es como su propio nombre indica, pues es un lenguaje
bastante sencillo, que lógicamente requiere una formación, en 3D Station podéis insertar
distintas estrategias, podés insert strategy, tienes ya un montón de elementos precreados,
de acuerdo, que vienen ya preinstalados en la plataforma, y que además todos son totalmente
editables y consultables, eso es muy importante, vale, solo como no hemos fijaros que lo que
acaba en LX es long exit, vale, lo que acaba en SX es short exit y lo que acaba en LE es
long entry y lo que acaba en SE es short entry, vale, entonces esa es un poco la pauta,
que también lo veis en las columnas, vale, el que hace buy, hace sell, hace short, vale,
cover, sell en 3D Station es cerrar largos, vale, no es abrir cortos, abrir cortos es
short, vale, y cover es cerrar cortos, de acuerdo, entonces aquí veis en las pestañitas
lo que marca cada elemento que hace, y esto que es muy sencillito, pues está muy bien,
es una manera de empezar, veis bollinger bands, entradas largas, bollinger bands, entradas
cortas, pues con eso montas un sistema para empezar, no quiero decir que con eso ya es
C, pero bueno, es una manera de empezar, porque luego también tenemos las salidas, tenemos
un montón de salidas precreadas, bueno, encontraré alguna que me acorde ahora, bueno, es igual
aquí salidas por parabólico, salidas por porcentaje, stop porcentaje, por un stop trailing,
un poco corto, por un profit target, por cierre en beneficio, bueno, hay realmente
muchas, por supuesto pues podéis importar varios y tal, aquí por expansiones de volatilidad,
hay realmente un montón y más normales, por un stop monetario por ejemplo también
está, vale, y como decía, lo muy bueno que es, es que tú simplemente das aquí, tienes
dos colas, una le das a definición, eso sí, va a ser en inglés, pero aquí los que lo
dominéis pues perfecto y aquellos que no pues usáis Google Translator, que quieras
o no, poco pues orienta, aquí ya tenéis una pequeña explicación de todos los indicadores
que tiene, eso es realmente muy útil porque te ayuda a situarte exactamente lo que hace,
¿no?, lo que hace, la verdad que es bastante completa, y luego el Easy Language, ¿de acuerdo?,
veis el código, y esto realmente es la mejor manera de aprender, de iniciarse, de iniciarse
un poquito en Easy Language, bueno, porque entendiendo cómo ellos han solucionado esta
estrategia, que en este caso es un People Reversal de entrada, vale, pues bueno, pues
tú puedes aprender, porque ahora aquí mismo lo mismo, en este singlón pulsas F1 y automáticamente
te va a abrir la ayuda y te va a explicar qué es esa función, ¿de acuerdo?, entonces
pues bueno, es una manera de ir poquito a poco aprendiendo, ¿de acuerdo?, y familiarizarse,
vale, esto voy rápido porque esto está tratado en el webinar 6, ¿eh?, porque ya soy consciente
que estoy yendo rápido, que sencillamente es un pequeño recordatorio de lo que tratamos
en el anterior, aquí fijaros que tengo justamente insertados entradas de Bollinger largas,
entradas de Bollinger cortas y un Stop Loss de 700 dólares, pues bueno, ese sistema hace
eso de entrada largo y corto y si pierden a un momento 700 dólares, como es aquí,
pues cierra, a ver que las líneas están, voy a ponerlas para que se vean bien en ambos
casos, no es esta, es justo la que no coges, siempre es esa, no es esa, voy a ver cuál
me falta, ah, que si no se confunde con las bandas de Bollinger, ya se lo voy a saber
más claro, vale, esto que está, no está optimizado ni nada ese sistema, eh, seguramente,
digo yo que será perdedor esto porque, bueno, mucho sería que ganara dinero, la verdad,
pero bueno, pues mira, gana dinero todo, es que hasta de oídas soy bueno, hay que ver,
elijo un sistema hacia ojo y lo elijo, por supuesto es broma porque esto ya os gratizo
que no ganará dinero, aunque tiene, es probable que no tenga comisiones, exacto, no tiene
comisiones, vale, no tiene comisiones, con lo cual seguro, casi seguro que con las comisiones
ya sería perdedor porque tiene un profit factor de 106 solo, vale, pero bueno, es un
sencillo ejemplo con los parámetros por defecto del Bollinger Bands en 15 minutos en el futuro
del DAX y con un stop loss de 700 dólares. Aplicaros que estos señales de stop que tiene
3x6 normalmente son intra barras, claro, o sea que eso es bastante útil porque hay muchas
plataformas que normalmente ponen el stop en la barra de entrada suele ser bastante problemático,
se puede hacer, pero normalmente con una programación standard por decirlo no entra porque el sistema
lee que el sistema está largo cuando acaba la barra actual, hay una sentencia típica
que es Get Mark Sentry por ejemplo o Market Position, es igual, ¿cómo está el sistema?
Claro, la lee que está en este caso largo cuando acaba, en cambio de decisiones es capaz
de leerlo durante la barra de entrada, por lo tanto si pierde 700 dólares en este caso
la barra de entrada sale, ¿cómo ha pasado aquí? Dos veces, ¿veis? Vale, entonces en
este webinar de hoy nos vamos a sentar en lo que es la optimización, quería sencillamente
comentaros lo de los herramientas de backtesting, esta era una, también os hablé del inside
bar backtesting, no voy a mostraros pero sencillamente no voy ahora a poneros el ejemplo que os puse
porque lleva un poquito de tiempo, pero sencillamente recordar que es un tema bastante importante
que no todas las plataformas contemplan, cuando una barra tiene lugar, lo explico brevemente
porque es importante, una barra tiene lugar en tiempo real como esta que se está construyendo
ahora mismo 15 minutos, esta barra si aquí hubiera un sistema aplicado como lo hay de
hecho, pues el sistema sabe rápidamente qué precio, si salta un stop o no salta un stop
porque el curso del tiempo, digamos que tiene claro cómo se construye la barra, en cambio
el sistema ya, esta barra por ejemplo que veis aquí no tiene ni idea cómo se ha construido,
es backtesting esto ya, esta barra no sabes cómo se ha construido, sabes que ha abierto
aquí, sabes que ha cerrado aquí y que ha hecho un mínimo aquí y un máximo aquí,
en este caso muy probablemente puedes pensar que ha sido casi el mínimo, se ha ido máximo
y ha vuelto, esta probablemente haya sido así, pero no siempre ocurre lo que parece
y no siempre es fácil averiguar lo que ha ocurrido, para solucionar esto todas las plataformas
digamos que tienen un algoritmo que calcula, que estiman cómo se ha construido la barra,
pero no lo saben con certeza todas, algunas de ellas sí, Interestation es una de ellas
con esta función que se llama look inside bar backtesting que la encontráis aquí,
esta función si se activa, bueno ahora mismo en este sistema no sé si tendrá efecto,
pero bueno vamos a verificarlo obviamente si tiene efecto, sería fantástico que lo
tuviera, esto lo activamos con un minuto, esto qué hace, esto comprueba con un histórico
paralelo, en este sistema no actúa, con un histórico paralelo comprueba cómo se ha
construido esa barra de 15 minutos en un minuto, por lo tanto sabe qué precio se ha tocado
antes y sobre todo en sistemas que tienen estrategia de entrada y estrategia de salida
por profit y salida por pérdidas, normalmente suele actuar y suele dar resultados bastante
dispares y alguna vez muy dispares, entonces no en todos los sistemas actúa, pero es una
herramienta de backtesting que aporta muchísima fiabilidad y que nos permite tener prácticamente
la certeza que testamos la realidad de lo que esperamos y hay otras plataformas que
no lo hacen eso y no puedes testearlo, yo utilizo un minuto normalmente, puedes hacerlo
en ticks, puedes hacerlo incluso en ticks, lo que pasa que en ticks el problema que tienes
es que solo tienes seis meses de histórico, entonces claro solo vas a poder comprobar
seis meses, en minuto como tienes todo pues ya pones un minuto, pero puedes poner hasta
20 segundos, si quieres o sea 20 segundos, el que le digas lo va a usar, pero normalmente
con un minuto incluso a veces en más, en 5 o en 15, evidentemente esto hace más lenta
la optimización, entonces a veces si ves que es poco sensible le pones 30 minutos
y luego le pones uno a ver cómo actúa, vas viendo cómo trabaja, pero en la mayoría
de sistemas tiene algún efecto, en algunos es muy notable, en algunos es muy poco y algunos
nada, aquí porque solo hay un stop, el sistema solo puede salir por esa señal, le da igual
saber cuando lo ha tocado porque cuando lo toca sale, realmente el debate está cuando
puede tocar varias órdenes, cuando esta variable actúa es cuando hay varias órdenes de salida
en el mercado, sean de profit o de win, cuando hay varias órdenes de salida no siempre sabes
exactamente cuál de ellas ha saltado primero o de entrada o un stop and reverse por ejemplo,
pero en el webinar 6 vimos un ejemplo que era bastante exagerado que aplicaba mucho,
que realmente se está, bueno aquellos que están siguiendo el mercado el DAX se está
dando la vuelta al alza, aprovechamos, mercado en directo. Y luego nada, también Transition
tiene algunas funciones fitness que hasta se han extendido a otras plataformas, la verdad
que no tienen nada, pero el Transition Index por ejemplo es un fitness que usa Transition
porque ya usan otras, también tiene a nivel de estadísticos el RINA porque como RINA
tiene una colaboración con Transition solo usa Transition, el RINA Index que sale en
el Performance Report, bueno, pero esto son cosas que al final también tampoco son super
destacadas, la más destacable en backtesting la vamos a ver hoy que es hablando de backtesting
de un sistema concreto es el World Forward Optimizer que vamos a pasar a verlo. Bien,
como os decía hoy vamos a hablar mucho de optimización, al final la optimización aquellos
que estéis familiarizados con el sistema pues ya sabéis lo que es, pero aquellos que
no lo estéis pues sencillamente es un proceso de búsqueda de valores óptimos que cumplen
una determinada condición, una determinada objetivo, un target, y se utiliza para, como
pongo aquí, ahora veremos que es un debate bastante interesante, yo ya os digo que soy
completamente partidario de la optimización pero bueno hay gente que no lo es, es un debate
interesante y hay razones en ambos sentidos, esto como la derecha y la izquierda, los de
la derecha dan argumentos para la derecha, los de la izquierda dan argumentos para la
derecha, bueno, quien tiene razón pues depende, depende de cada momento supongo, entonces
realmente la optimización en términos general en estadísticas se utiliza para un montón
de cosas, entonces es un proceso para mi que sé que hay que utilizarlo, es verdad
que tiene pues como casi todas las herramientas muy potentes tienen peligros porque un Fórmula
1 es una máquina realmente muy potente y seguramente las manos menos de las mías sería
un peligro bastante importante, pero Alonso no lo lleva mal, lo maneja bien, entonces
al final todas las herramientas muy potentes en sí conllevan riesgos, porque justamente
su potencia en su potencia deriva su riesgo, pero el hecho de que tenga riesgos no implica
que no debamos usarlo, en mi opinión supongo como los futuros, los futuros son muy peligrosos,
no los futuros no son peligrosos, lo que son peligrosos es el que usa mal los futuros,
pero el futuro en sí, uno puede operar un futuro sin apalancamiento exactamente igual
que un ETF y mucho más barato, realmente no tiene peligro en sí el concepto, lo que
pasa es que el futuro permite un apalancamiento como otros activos que si no se usa bien pues
es peligroso, sería una analogía de este tipo, entonces en mi opinión sí que hay
que usarla pero hay que utilizarla con buen criterio, me he insultado porque es el mismo
tema que tengo yo, digo se me ha olvidado, entonces como os decía hay que usarlo con
buen criterio y hoy en día tenemos herramientas como vais a ver el World Forward Optimizer
que nos ayuda muchísimo a medir la robustez del sistema que es al final lo que buscamos,
al final cuando hacemos un sistema lo que buscamos es que gane dinero, eso es más bien
obvio, el problema es que todavía no podemos conocer el futuro y al final lo backtesteamos
en datos pasados, es la herramienta que tenemos para comprobar o para validar si una idea
creemos que es buena, pero realmente los resultados pasados no garantizan los futuros, frase típica
del sector financiero, eso es cierto, pero si realmente trabajamos bien esta optimización
y utilizamos herramientas como la que vais a ver ahora posteriormente, pues podemos entre
comillas fabricar datos futuros, podemos fabricar datos futuros o live, ya lo vamos a ver entre
comillas, esta es la típica frase que la sacan fuera de contexto y estas muerta, pero eso
es en las comillas. Bueno aquí brevemente no quiero extenderme
mucho en conceptos teóricos, que luego esto queda grabado y podéis leerlo con calma,
aunque no sé si se le da muy bien en el ordenador, pero bueno, bien, fantástico, bueno, seguro
que habéis oído hablar de concepto de sobre-optimizar y concepto de robustez que se puede definir
de muchas maneras, yo os la he definido de una manera más bien pragmática, porque hablamos
muchas veces de robustez, a veces con ligereza, porque realmente la robustez lo que podemos
hacer es fomentarla, intentar buscarla, pero realmente hasta que no opere en real no lo
sabemos si es robusto, la robustez de verdad es que el sistema opera y va como esperábamos
en el backtesting, entonces a priori decimos, hombre, es un sistema que va más activos
es más robusto, bueno, a priori sí, un sistema que pasa el World Forward Optimizer con buenas
pruebas es robusto, bien, a priori sí, pero hasta que no opere realmente no vamos a saber
si realmente es realmente robusto, porque al final estamos en un entorno de incertidumbre.
El tema de la muestra, cuando optimizamos esto, antes previamente aquí había un debate
interesante antes de empezar sobre los grados de libertad, sobre la optimización, sobre
la muestra y demás, al final la muestra debe ser o debería de ser en términos generales,
porque hay excepciones, vamos a ver que con World Forward Optimizer vamos a intentar mantener
estos dos criterios, pero siendo un poco más laxos veréis por qué, al final tiene que
ser representativa del universo, es decir, contra más tipos de mercado tengamos en un
backtesting mejor, de acuerdo, si yo cojo un mercado que es, estoy optimizando un sistema
en el futuro del DAX, quiero que haya mercados bajistas, alcistas, volátiles, poco volátiles,
laterales, contra más tipos de mercado haya más fácil o más probable es que el mercado,
el sistema se haya adaptado bien a todos los mercados, pero luego aparte de eso tiene que
ser estadísticamente significativa, porque de nada me sirve si ese estudio es representativo
al final tiene 5 traits, porque por muy representativo que sea del universo objeto de estudio realmente
no es estadísticamente significativo, entonces hay que buscar un poquito los dos, ya que os
ponía más grados de libertad, más significaciones necesitamos, esto pues utilizamos la TV Studen
normalmente para medirlo, aunque la verdad la TV Studen me parece muy poco agresiva,
quiero decir que se pasa con mucha facilidad, o sea realmente no pasarla, si no la pasas
realmente es que tienes muy muy pocos traits y realmente el beneficio por traits es muy
bajo, realmente se suele pasar, pero hay que pasarla, y luego el otro método importantísimo
de que medimos robustez y que buscamos que un sistema, o valorar si un sistema funciona
en live es lo que llamamos la prueba externa, que es donde vamos a entrar ahora en el Google
Forward Optimizer que vais a ver en breve, el World Forward clásico ahora muy breve
os lo voy a enseñar lo que es en TV Station, eso sí que la mayoría de plataformas de sistemas
lo tiene, al final tampoco todas, hay algunas que hay que hacerlo manualmente, sabéis que
siempre son muy gracios, hay gente que luego me lo dice, pero por qué no lo dice, porque
no me gusta nunca hablar de, además yo plataformas trabajo muchas, pero voy a hablar de una en
este caso, por ejemplo en caso de VisualChar, no tiene World Forward ni clásico, o sea
tú tienes que hacer tu backtest en un periodo y luego tu probarlo en otro periodo por tu
cuenta, pero hay muchas plataformas que este proceso lo hacen implementado, o sea que ya
te dejan decir qué parte pones dentro y qué parte pones fuera del histórico y ya te sacan
las estadísticas, digamos que es más rápido, pero esto no es para nada exclusivo de TV
Station, no tiene muchas plataformas, el World Forward clásico, y luego está el Self-Adaptative,
que nada, no voy a hacer nada más sobre ello, que esto ya es un avanzado, son sistemas que
en el código ya se autoajustan al mercado y que el World Forward va muy bien para eso,
luego lo vamos a ver. ¿Qué es el World Forward convencional? Pues bueno, por ejemplo este
sistema que tenemos aquí, vamos a hacer muy breve que veáis una optimización clásica
para aquellos que no estáis familiarizados con TV Station, en el menú para elegir las
funciones fitness, en el menú VIEW tenéis el Chart Analysis Preferences y hay una pestaña
que es Strategy, aquí es un poco donde se controlan las opciones generales de optimización
y donde se elige la función fitness, la función objetivo que vamos a optimizar, bueno hay
varias, a mí personalmente digo porque siempre es una pregunta que me hacen, ya lo digo,
a mí me gusta mucho el Expectancy Score, me gusta mucho el TV Station Index y me gusta
mucho el Perfect Profit Correlation y sin desmenecer nada a Profit Factor, que mi compañero
Roberto le gusta mucho por ejemplo, al final la mayoría, como ya he dicho muchas veces,
no todos pero la mayoría tienen una elevada correlación entre ellos, es decir, normalmente
un buen sistema suele salir bien en todo, o sea, debería de salir siempre que sean
de rentabilidad riesgo, claro si uno coge máximo consecutivo de perdidos a lo mejor
uno sale, pero es decir, siempre que utiliza algún ratio de rentabilidad riesgo, cualquiera
de ellos, normalmente van a salir parecidos las zonas, de acuerdo, parecidos, no tendremos
que ser igual, pero aquí se elige, se elige cómo se ordenan, en principio esto es lo
que os quiero explicar de esta ventana, luego vamos a Format, o hacéis doble clic encima
de una orden, de una flechita, o si no habéis el menú Format, Format Strategies o botón
derecho, que es la manera un poco más sencilla, sale todo, encima del gráfico sale Format
Strategies, aquí salen los sistemas que están insertados, en la pestaña Properties for All
están estas opciones que habéis visto de si usamos el Look Inside Verbal Testing o no,
lo vamos a desconectar, porque ya hemos visto que no actuaba y para esta prueba no da igual,
Comisiones, vamos a poner 3, bueno 3 no, porque 2 ya es mucho porque en Trail Station
el futuro del DAX a veces cuesta 1.20, no 30€, cuesta 1.20 dólares más 0.50, no,
sí, más o menos, ponemos 2 euros, sale por un poco menos, por euro y pico, vale, Slip
Bajé para el DAX, Roberto, 12, 15, 20, 15 euros, por contrato, euros, es, es, el punto
del DAX son 25, pues bueno, medio punto es medio punto, es un poco más de medio punto,
yo creo que es menos, pero bueno, es igual, no pasa nada, esto es una mera, una mera prueba,
aquí en el Backtesting normalmente lo vais a tocar, pero que sepáis, aquellos que no
estéis familiarizados, pues bueno, si usáis órdenes limitadas hay que elegir cómo simula
el hecho de las órdenes limitadas, porque ya sabéis que con una orden limitada no podemos
estar seguros que se ha ejecutado, porque te puedes quedar en la cola cuando se toca
el precio, entonces bueno, aquí te dice que qué asumciones quieres hacer con una orden
limitada, que ejecute cuando lo toca, que ejecute cuando excede el límite y luego incluso
combinaciones de que la marca ejecutada cuando se ejecuta al menos un número determinado
de acciones en ese precio, eso es bastante interesante, esto normalmente hay que dejarlo
por defecto, si queremos penalizar extra las órdenes con un slippage adicional a las órdenes
a mercado, además del que hemos fijado aquí, si queremos que las órdenes a mercado tengan
un slippage adicional y estas opciones de automatización que lo explicaré al final previamente, para
conectarlo a tiempo real al mercado, pero a lo mismo no nos importa, también hay aquí
si no están en el código, si no está en el código las órdenes de gestión de contratos,
pero el código puedes por supuesto modificarlo, puedes poner euros por trade o número de contratos
fijos y ya está, entonces aquí para optimizar desde el menú format en inputs, vamos a optimizar
simplemente, no nos complicamos, con un incremento, optimizar, no, es que el sistema está aplicado
en un time frame concreto, no se puede optimizar con código avanzado, bueno preguntan perdonad
porque aquí no lo es claro, las preguntas en internet, preguntan si pueden optimizar
varios time frames, estamos comentando que al principio el gráfico está insertado sobre
un time frame y tú optimizas ese y luego Roberto que está aquí también de
Desensant Systems, pues comenta que con código avanzado se puede hacer de, se puede hacer
programente, con código avanzado prácticamente no voy a decir todo porque no, porque todo
no se puede, pero realmente se puede casi todo lo que es objetivizable, porque además
hoy en día ICLenguage cada vez es más abierto y tiene más objetos externos, se puede llamar
bases de datos externas, de Excel, realmente se pueden trabajar de manera muy flexible,
todo no, insisto, pero por código se puede hacer casi todo, pasa que ya hay cosas pues
un poquito más complicadas, que yo mismo por ejemplo sería capaz, para eso está Roberto
que sí que es capaz de todo y más. Entonces por ejemplo aquí optimizamos la banda
de Bollinger y es 32, vamos a dejar la desviación porque es una probabilidad que queremos hacer
las dos, optimizamos la misma, la otra para el otro lado y el stop lo dejamos o no, vamos
a optimizar un poco el stop también, vamos a poner desde 500 a 1500, 250, 2000, vale.
Esto aquí fijaros que os salen las opciones, esta línea de abajo no debe salir, eso es
un fallo de mi portátil de hace tiempo, en ningún ordenador me pasa, pero aquí no sé,
como que no encajan las ventanas, no sé por qué, me pasaron varios problemas, no solo
con 3D, entonces alguna historia interna del portátil, pero aquí esto se debe ver mejor
que aquí, optimización siempre tenéis dos tipos, ya la standard y la world forward,
luego la veremos porque la world forward es la que nos lleva al world forward ultimizer,
la optimización standard que puede ser exhaustiva o genética, si le dais a advanced settings
fijaros que aquí es donde marcáis el periodo que dejáis fuera de muestra, este es el world
forward clásico que os decía antes en el powerpoint, aquí le ponemos el outsample
window, es decir que parte del histórico quieres que no optimice, por defecto pone 30
pero podés cambiarlo y podés incluso poner una parte inicial y una parte final como quieras,
normalmente se deja 30, 20, 10% de visual, depende de la cantidad de muestra, y luego
las opciones del optimizador automático que al principio le das a su jest y te las va
a tocar, se puede tocar las pruebas de stress pero no toca, bueno esto depende, esto depende
mucho, no hay una regla absoluta, realmente depende del tipo de sistema, si es un sistema
que va en gráfico diario, es un sistema que va en intradía, es un sistema que tiene
pocos straights, muchos straights, en todas formas déjame que luego cuando hablemos del
world forward ultimizer vamos a entrar un poco más en este concepto de periodos que
es muy muy interesante, pero luego quizá vamos a entrar mejor, aquí ya no me deja
hacer lo genético porque realmente hay muy pocas combinaciones, no me deja elegir, bueno
no se me deja no, no me deja cambiarlo, no, me va a decir que lo haga exhaustivo porque
hay muy pocas, esto ahora lo va a hacer, no sé si va rápido, no sé cuánto histórico
he cargado, aquí ni me he fijado, no, hay demasiado histórico, bueno lo vamos a dejar
ahí, le he dejado el 30% fuera de muestra, bueno entonces esto aquí va haciendo su proceso
y ahora veréis que nos va a sacar una estadística con los datos in sample, los datos auto sample
no optimizados y conjuntos, esto sería el world forward clásico que me estaba refiriendo
aquí, el world forward clásico, que consiste en optimizar un histórico y dejar libre
otro, hay plataformas que no lo permiten hacer ya directamente y tú optimizas una
parte y lo pruebas en otra, pero evidentemente es mucho más rápido así, porque además
nos permite unir los datos ya en una estadística y además es realmente mucho más sencillo,
no sé cuánto histórico he cargado aquí, normalmente va remontando, cuando a veces
pone una hora y al final son 30 minutos, bueno seguimos en todo el caso avanzando un poco
la teoría y ahora cuando nos acabe pues volvemos aquí, entonces en que supone que es el world
forward avanzado, lo vais a ver mejor en una imagen, esto es una aplicación que forma
parte de the station, pero es una aplicación por sí sola, se llama world forward optimizer,
esta aplicación te permite, como pongo aquí un poco, pues empieza realmente cuando el
resto de métodos de backtesting acaban, como os decía antes es bastante parecido a probar
con datos futuros, porque aquí en este world forward clásico que acabamos de hacer hemos
visto una optimización, con un periodo in sample y otro periodo auto sample que ahora
cuando acabe veremos, el world forward optimizer lo que hace es en un único proceso hacer
centenares de muestras distintas, lo vais a ver en un ejemplo práctico, lo voy a enseñar
para que lo veáis, hace centenares, de tal manera que yo puedo combinar, aquí que hemos
hecho en este ejemplo, hemos optimizado el 70% histórico y hemos dejado el 30% fuera,
en este ejemplo que se está ahora optimizando, pero yo puedo hacer también 80-20 o 90-10
o 60-40, puedo variar la ventana, puedo variar la ventana y puedo variar el número de runes,
el número de cortes, aquí fijaros cada rune para que lo entendáis en este gráfico, es
una simplificación por meses, no tiene por qué ser natural por meses, las fuentes pueden
cambiar pero sencillamente para que, aquí al final el periodo de optimización es de
5 meses, 4 se optimizan y 1 no, es 20%, optimizo el 80% y el 20% lo dejo fuera, igual aquí,
pero fijaros que esto es un rune, esto es otro rune, esto es otro, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7 y 8,
en total ha hecho 8 runes, y lo mismo, yo puedo variar esta ventana que en este caso
en esta pantalla es 80-20, pero también puedo variar el número de runes, o sea porque
hago 8 y no hago 5 o no hago 15, porque esto moviendo donde, el hecho, fijaros aquí que
este periodo que inicia, inicia en el mes 1 y este inicia en el mes 2 y este inicia
en el mes 3, se inicia en el mes 4, esto es así ya digo porque es una ejemplificación
pero no tiene por qué ser así, este podría empezar en el mes 3 y este en el mes 5 y
este en el mes 7 y por lo tanto en medio de 8 pues hacer 4 o al revés, podría empezar
justo aquí, en el mes y medio y en el 2 mes y medio y en vez de 8 hacer 12, 12 runes.
Estas dos, voy a ir un poco adelante y atrás ahora para intentar explicaros lo mejor que
pueda, estas dos variables, es decir el porcentaje que yo dejo fuera de mostra, normalmente elegimos
entre el 5 y el 30% como veis aquí y el número de runes que hacemos, son las dos variables
claves para hacer un World Forward Ultimizer, que insisto vais a ver en un ejemplo práctico.
Aquí variamos estas dos variables, en este ejemplo práctico de 5 a 30% fuera de muestra
con incrementos de 5% y con de 4 a 12 runes de 1 en 1, es decir 4, 5, 6, hacemos un montón
de runes distintos, de tal manera veis aquí tenéis, que luego lo veréis cuando acabe
este que está haciendo ahora, aquí tenéis una copia de uno de ellos, es este, en la
columna primera tenéis fuera de muestra de 5 a 30% y en la fila de la cabecera veis
que van los runes del 4 al 11, que hay equipos de 12 pero es al 11, son distintos runes,
o sea un rune es esto, es cada fila, un rune es cada fila, ahora lo vas a ver, lo hace
todo en un proceso el solo, si si si, un proceso muy intensivo y además hace unas pruebas
a cada set que ahora lo vais a ver, realmente lo destacable no es solo el hecho de probarlo
sino que luego te da datos sobre ello, luego te da datos de cada una de ellas, de cada
una de ellas, entonces aquí obtenemos cada combinación, este cluster, esta casilla que
es 5% fuera de muestra y 4 runs, y esta de aquí es 20% fuera de muestra y 7 runs, cada
una de ellas pues así, y todas ellas, de todas ellas vas a poder ver todos los datos,
por lo tanto, recapitulando, recapitulando, como os decía en la definición inicial es
un proceso que hace sucesivas optimizaciones, aplicando, o sea, hace sucesivas optimizaciones,
sucesivos runs con una ventana elegida concreta, los mejores parámetros que obtienen ese
set los aplica un periodo fuera de muestra y en ese caso igual que hace la optimización
clásica wall forward, lo que pasa que lo hace en muchos sets conjunto y que nos da
los datos agrupados luego, luego podemos ver todos estos datos de manera agrupada, ahora
lo vais a ver que es realmente fantástico, por eso decía antes no de las comillas de
qué lo vuelvo a poner, es como probar el sistema de datos futuros porque realmente
es así, realmente tú puedes construir con este método un histórico fuera de muestra
muy largo, de mucho tiempo atrás, o sea, que hubiera pasado si en el pasado yo hubiera
hecho wall forward y hubiera aplicado, que hubiera pasado si, esa es un poco la clave,
por eso entre comillas insisto hablamos de fabricar datos futuros, estas son una de las
preguntas típicas que responde wall forward optimizer que además equivale a decir si
es robusto mi sistema, lo resumimos así, pero un sistema robusto pues sería esto, un
sistema que gane dinero después de optimizar gane dinero, no, eso es lo que queremos,
pues este aplicación intenta responder a eso, bueno no intenta, responde a eso, o sea responde
objetivamente a eso, otra cosa insisto, esto lo comento siempre, no quiere decir que un
sistema que pase el wall forward optimizer va a ganar dinero en el mercado seguro, eso
es imposible porque el mercado cambia y si el mercado puede automáticamente hacer un
cambio que no ha estado contemplado nunca en el histórico el sistema dejará de ganar
dinero. Desde luego con esta aplicación podemos objetivar la robustez, yo puedo decir objetivamente
que ese sistema es robusto en este momento, ahora, lo que no puedo decir es si el futuro
del mercado que hará, pero si puedo llegar a esta conclusión que hasta ahora pues no
será muy difícil llegar, realmente utilizabamos con excel, hacíamos wall forward, pero incluso
las pruebas que hemos hecho todos en excel mezclando histórico tal no llegan a este
nivel nunca, ahora lo vais a ver porque los datos que obtenemos son tremendos, y una cosa
que es realmente que nosotros en Cersan Sistemas que ya sabéis que además de estar explicándolos
y intentando formar a todo el país, bueno a los interesados en 3 session pues intentamos
hacerlo no, pero además somos desarrolladores de sistemas y nosotros intentamos aplicar
esta última casilla que veis aquí, de que cada cuanto tiempo debemos reoptimizar nuestro
sistema y wall forward automation también responde a eso, no en todos los casos, porque
depende de la muestra si es significativa o no, aquello que os decía antes necesitamos
que la muestra sea significativa, pero si la muestra es significativa normalmente vamos
a poder también programar la reoptimización del sistema, nosotros ahora mismo tenemos
un sistema operando, o sea este set que os voy a dar, ahora os voy a enseñar un wall
forward en el programa original, de verdad este es el set, perdón este es el wall forward
que ha elegido los parámetros de nemesis de un sistema que está en el mercado operando
en tiempo real ahora mismo, o sea que es 100% real, estos son algunos de los gráficos que
vamos a ver ahora mismo, pero no me extendo aquí porque un poco lo pongo como por seguridad
por si no me fuera la conexión o algo, pues no tengo y puedo hablar de ello, pero estas
mismas tablas las vais a ver ahora en situ, antes recapitulemos un momentito que nos va
a ayudar a comprender un poquito todo esto, aquellos que estén familiarizados con sistemas
puede resultar más o menos entendible, pero realmente si no pues es un concepto que puede
resultar un tanto complejo, la optimización que habíamos puesto con el wall forward clásico
ya ha acabado, cuando acaba aparece el gráfico, no nos la abre, tenemos que ir a la opción
view, strategy, optimización report o darle al myusov por acceso directo al teclado,
por ejemplo aquí y os va a abrir el histórico, el informe de la optimización, fijaros que
arriba hay tres tipos de datos, all data, in sample data y out of sample data, es decir
aquello que os decía que habíamos elegido aquella ventana del 30% ya tenéis los datos
separados, esto normalmente los portamos, debemos aguardar y los sacamos cada uno de
ellos y lo portamos en excel, digamos que puedes trabajar mejor con los datos. Un dato
muy destacable que da TrayStation ya aquí en este informe, que insisto esto es el wall
forward clásico, esta optimización es normal y corriente solo que ya nos permite ver este
wall forward, tiene una última columna que se llama el robotness index, que no es más
que si el sistema está ganando lo mismo anualmente en la parte fuera de muestra que
la parte optimizada, en este caso fijaros que el mejor ordenado por expectancy score
porque es el que hemos elegido, que está marcado en gris, en el conjunto de datos fijaros
que fuera de muestra lo ha hecho un 55% peor, no ha ido bien, en cambio aquí tenemos el
tercero que lo ha hecho mejor, realmente lo ha hecho un 288 mejor, se ha ido muy bien
fuera de muestra, esto realmente es una muestra que tiene 403, para una intradía me gustaría
que tuviera más pero no está mal, no es una mala muestra, entonces si ahora por ejemplo
aplicamos este conjunto, no vamos a complicarnos mucho la vida, esto es solo para que veáis
como funciona, aquí si haces doble clic estos parámetros ahora mismo me los ha aplicado
al sistema, me los ha cambiado, este que es set zone, pues son en vez del 20 por defectos
30, el periodo 30 que se ha ido a la banda alta y si que el stop más o menos lo mantiene
siendo 50, 1000 en esa zona más bien baja, pero fijaros que el periodo lo quiere aumentar
un poco, quiere ir un poco más lento, porque le hemos puesto comisiones entonces a la que
el operar empieza a costar dinero normalmente quiere operar menos, eso suele pasar, entonces
esta es una optimización normal, esto aquí podemos exportarlo a excel, podemos exportarlo
a excel y trabajarlo y mezclarlo, nosotros a modo de ejemplo, que veáis un poquito el
proceso sencillamente, nosotros hacemos optimizaciones de muchos tipos, esto por favor no divulgáis
nada, que tendría que mataros luego, a ver si lo encuentro, no está aquí, no está
aquí, aquí, estos son world forward, pero es igual efectos del dato es lo mismo, esto
por ejemplo, aquí tienes la tabla insample, la tabla autosample, la tabla load data, aquí
hacemos luego unos distintos vistores y los trabajamos, pero al final apuntamos un poquito
los datos de la optimización, etcétera, no lo he oído, perdón, ¿me puedo repetir?
Sí sí, puedes hacerlo antes o después, puedes dejarlos, ahora lo he comentado, esto es un
excel a título de muestra, nosotros lo exportamos y aquí trabajas, aquí el property for alls
en el, ya lo diré, aquí por ejemplo, vamos a poner por probarlo solo, aquí en el advanced
settings, aquí escrut first, aquí excluye histórico por delante o por detrás, si quiere
puede poner 30% por delante y cero por detrás, en el world forward optimizer no, yo lo he
hecho lo primer día para ver que hacía y sé que lo hace pero no tiene sentido, realmente
no tiene sentido, realmente para el world forward optimizer lo que nos interesa es saber si
ha ido ganando dinero en el futuro, no en el pasado, no tendría, lo vamos a ver y creo
que queda claro, entonces si queremos hacer un world forward optimizer que tenemos que
hacer, porque esta es la optimización que hemos visto clásica, que también es interesante
y útil, es la que tiene la mayoría de plataformas, que insisto puede ser genética o exhaustiva,
en caso de three station, pero luego para hacer un world forward optimizer tenemos que venir
aquí y elegir world forward, a esto hay que ponerle un nombre, que será luego el nombre
que tendrá, es esto, este es de don chan porque es un canal de don chan que mi amigo
Roberto le gusta mucho y luego aquí, al final lo que se elige es un poco lo mismo, la ventana,
aquí realmente no importa porque luego la van a cambiar, pero bueno, podéis elegir
la ventana que dais, realmente no importa, el algoritmo y tal, pero lo mismo, puede ser
genética o exhaustiva, igual, o sea, tú puedes hacer un world forward optimizer genético
o exhaustivo, lo único que hay que marcarlo aquí, ponerle un nombre porque luego una
vez acabe la optimización aquí, lleve su tiempo, habrá que ir aquí y hacer otro proceso,
o sea, es un proceso en dos fases actualmente, de hecho están trabajando en versiones donde
esto está un poco más unificado, porque esto, esta app world forward optimizer lo compró
hace años a Grail, si buscas esto también encontrarás su formación, es una aplicación,
ya lo he dicho muchas veces, pero es que no me canso de decirlo, para mi es única, es
fantástica, entonces la compro y realmente la he ido integrando en 3D Station, pero bueno,
como que en cada versión que saca la integra un poco más, es decir, hay alguna cosita,
entonces aún realmente hay cosas que se ve, que se nota, que es una aplicación que se
externa y que ellos la están integrando, y esto es uno de ellos, porque realmente esto
la lógica sería que ya desde aquí pudieras ya hacer las dos cosas, pero realmente haces
un proceso aquí y luego vienes aquí y lo abres y haces otro, ahora mismo está así,
en la 9.5 que está en beta, en principio creo que hay alguna mejora en ese sentido,
no estoy seguro si cambia totalmente, pero hay alguna mejora en ese sentido, bueno, entonces
una vez se hace, a ver que voy a quitar aquí la optimización para que no me salga a optimizar,
entonces esto se acaba la optimización, sale también nuestro informe igual, o sea cuando
hacemos el World Forward Optimizer también sacamos el informe este y lo podemos llevar
a Excel, de hecho ese que os he abierto era uno de World Forward, pero desde aquí vamos
a cargar el histórico y le vamos a hacer un proceso de World Forward ¿Vale? ¿Cómo se
hace un proceso de World Forward Optimizer? Esto que veis es la aplicación en cuestión,
que se abre desde dentro de 3D Station, es una de ellas, de todas estas que hay aquí,
entonces es esta World Forward Optimizer ¿Vale? Esto se abre, esa clic y aparece ese
programa ¿Vale? Aparece ese programa, bueno voy a abrirlo así de momento, aparece así,
abres un set que hemos optimizado que está aquí ¿Vale? Y aquí ahora eliges unas determinadas
opciones que os voy a explicar como se hace ¿Vale? Primero el criterio, bueno antes no
os he explicado las pruebas, os lo voy a explicar brevemente porque eso creo que es muy importante,
no solo el hecho de que, no solo el hecho de estos sets que habéis visto, todo este
cluster está mezclado entre autosample y run, sino esto que veis aquí, pass y fail,
que es ¿Vale? Esto verde tan chulo que es ¿Vale? Realmente al final el WFE lo que hace
en realidad es una prueba de estrés muy fuerte ¿Vale? Y nos va a dar al final un resultado
de pass o fail de cada uno de los clusters pero también en global ¿Vale? Él nos va
a decir si cree que el sistema pasa esta prueba ¿Vale? Y en que consiste pasar esta prueba
¿Vale? ¿En que consiste pasar esta prueba? Pues pasar esta prueba son estos 5 sets ¿Vale?
Estos 5 pruebas ¿Vale? Primero de ellos, que son configurables ¿Vale? Me vuelvo al
WF porque os lo voy a enseñar aquí ¿Vale? Son configurables, él tiene estos por defecto
pero son estas 5 que veis aquí, criterio 1, criterio 2, criterio 3, criterio 4, criterio
5 ¿Vale? El criterio 5 es que el sistema gane dinero ¿Vale? Parece bastante, con datos fuera
de muestra ¿Eh? ¿De acuerdo? O sea todas estas pruebas son a los datos o a la comparación
entre los datos fuera de muestra y optimizados, es decir los datos out of sample y in sample
¿Vale? Entonces que el sistema en total fuera de muestra gane dinero, incluso yo puedo cambiarlo,
puedo hacerlo más exigente si quiero ¿Vale? Que el WF Efficiency sea mayor que el 50%,
el WF Efficiency es lo que os decía antes, es el beneficio, lo que gana el sistema anualizado
¿Vale? Que sea al menos el 50% fuera de muestra que lo que gana dentro de muestra, es decir
si el sistema gana un millón en ese set que al menos gane 500.000 fuera de muestra, con
eso pasaría, de nuevo se puede endurecer la prueba, si quieres ponerlo 80, 90 o 100 ¿Vale?
100, cuando un sistema tiene un WF Efficiency, bueno no un sistema, un determinado cluster
tiene un 100% quiere decir que gana exactamente lo mismo fuera de muestra que optimizado
que eso es lo ideal ¿No? Eso sería lo ideal que hiciera exactamente lo mismo, no es fácil
pero es lo ideal ¿Vale? Pero normalmente la industria considera que el hecho que gane
un 50 se considera apto, se considera razonable porque puede haber un mercado distinto ¿Vale?
Además aquí la, si tenemos más de 100, hombre entendido, pero si es muy reiterado
y se aleja mucho es sospechoso, es sospechoso, habría que mirarlo, no quiero decir que no,
puede ser porque puedes tener, a ver caso típico, tu pruebas un sistema muy tendencial
el periodo en sample es poco tendencial y justo cuando el periodo fuera de muestra tiene
una tendencia inhumana, por lo mejor una muestra pega un, ¿Vale? Pero que pasa aquí, que
aquí no hablamos de un solo set, ahora lo ves, hablamos de muchos runs, entonces realmente
es una prueba que por eso en si, porque hay gente que dice, hombre el 50 me parece un
poco laxo, bueno pero es que no es a 1, o sea realmente lo vas a ver en un conjunto,
o sea no es en un único run como el ejemplo que habéis visto ahora anteriormente en una
columna, ese es un run, en el estadístico que os he enseñado en 3stations, la tabla,
había la columna de la derecha, que ahí en uno ponía 200, otro menos 50, eso era
el world floor of efficiency, de 1, 70 a 30, este es de por ejemplo los 5 runs que hayan,
los 5 fuera de muestra, es decir es una media de todos, por lo tanto y cada uno de ellos
corresponde a un periodo distinto, por lo tanto es una prueba que se aplica mucho a
lo largo del tiempo, por lo tanto tiene mucha validez estadística, ¿de acuerdo? Consistencia
de los beneficios, es decir, que ninguno, no es en la distribución de los beneficios,
quiero decir ahora, exacto, que ninguno de ellos, bueno se puede poner que todos ganen
o que al menos el 50% de ellos tengan beneficios, es decir, si tú tienes 10 runs, con cuántos
crees que tienen que haber ganado o cuántos perdidos, si yo le pongo 50 quiere decir que
al menos el 5 runs tiene que haber ganado, si le pongo 80 pues creen que al menos en
8 tiene que haber ganado, ¿vale? Fuera de muestra, insisto, lo vais a ver ahora en
plática y luego la distribución, ese también es importante, aunque ojo que este a veces
los tendenciales le cuesta de pasar, aunque Nemesis lo ha pasado, pero le cuesta, lo ha
pasado por muy poco, por este variable, ¿vale? Porque que ninguno de los runs contribuya
más de, en este caso, el 50% del beneficio total, es decir, que no haya 2, 3 que no ganan
nada y en uno de golpe gane todo, eso tampoco, lo que nos gusta es que el sistema realmente
demuestre que ha ganado dinero en distintos periodos, no solo en uno de ellos, ¿no? Y
para acabar el último variable es que el drawdown sea, en este caso, que ninguno de
los sets tenga más de un 40% de drawdown, ¿vale? Sobre capital inicial, bueno, ahora
vamos a verlo en práctico porque aquí os he querido enseñar aquí y la verdad es que
creo que aquí queda muy engorroso. Ahora os lo voy a enseñar en el ejemplo práctico,
¿vale? Aquí abajo veis un poco la idea y es esto, ¿ves? Él te dice de cada uno de
ellos si lo pasa o no, de cada uno de ellos, te dice el global, el global es que los tiene
que pasar todos, o sea, nada más que no pase uno, lo marca felt, o sea, tiene que pasar
las 5, sí, sí, por eso digo, que dices, el hecho de que sea 50% me parece largo, no,
no, no, los tiene que pasar todos, ¿vale? Los tiene que pasar todos, los tiene que pasar
todos, ¿vale? Entonces, volviendo al World Forward, aquí realmente lo que os quería
enseñar es, bueno, defines el capital inicial, defines cuál es la función fitness que eliges
para hacer esta mezcla. Realmente en este caso podéis incluso utilizar el profit, ¿verdad?
Entonces, ya viene, o sea, esto ya se basa en la muestra que ha obtenido en la optimización
hecha antes de The Station, es decir, si tú ya hayas elegido un determinado criterio
por algoritmo genético, es ese ya, o sea, tú no vienes ya de la totalidad del histórico
sino vienes de la serie de trades que ha obtenido de una optimización, por lo tanto, aquella
muestra ya está sesgada por el fitness que hayáis elegido en The Station, ¿me explico?
Que hayáis elegido al hacer aquí, o sea, aquí hayáis una optimización por un criterio
concreto, ¿no? Por ejemplo, expectancy score, por lo tanto la muestra ya viene un poco sesgada
por ese criterio, ¿vale? Por lo tanto nosotros solemos utilizar una mezcla de los tres que
nos gustan, pero bueno, de verdad que no es, en el World Forward Optimization no está
relevante, se puede hacer por el profit, ¿vale? Y una vez hacemos el set up, el start el cluster
análisis y al final llegáis, una vez acaba el proceso, que dura lo suyo, recomiendo hacerlo
por la noche, llegáis a un resultado, ¿vale? Llegáis a un resultado, son horas dependiendo
de, bueno, es depende mucho de los trades, claro, si es un sistema diario que tiene pues
depende, puede estar horas, puede estar horas, pero a lo mejor un diario no lo puede hacer
en una hora, en dos, para que a lo mejor un interés pues se tarda cinco horas, tres,
depende, realmente depende, depende de la muestra que tú hayas puesto, ¿no? Comparativamente
es bastante rápido, creo yo, este proceso, comparativamente es más lenta la optimización
clásica en 3D Session que el World Forward, la optimización lenta en 3D Session es un
tanto lenta actualmente, aunque está, ahora mismo ya digo, la 9.5 está en beta y por
fin van a utilizar el multicore, entonces se va a acelerar mucho, que está ya en beta
2, con lo cual, pues no sé cuánto, no sé cuántos meses tardará, ¿cómo? Sí, si eres
cliente, tú eres cliente de 3D Session, pero tienes cuenta, tú tienes cuenta, pero si
tienes cuenta lo que puedes hacer es irte, bueno, luego te lo cuento, te puedes solicitar
e inscribirte al beta tester, sí, entonces te avisa y te la instala si quieres, ¿vale?
Ten en cuenta que en el que la instales solo va con uno, yo aquí por ejemplo, justamente
para mí, puedes tener instaladas las dos, pero solo puedes tener activa una de ellas,
o puedes pasar de una a otra, yo ayer pasé de la 9.5 a la 9.1 aquí, para evitar que
no se me colgara cualquier historia, porque es una beta y falla, pero ahora mismo yo si
hablo de la 9.5 me va a decir que no, que tengo que activarla, tarda un rato, o sea
que no puedes simultanear las dos en el mismo ordenador trabajando abiertas, sí, sí, sí,
en el ordenador, pero abiertas no puedes tener abiertas la 9.1, si tienes una abierta no
puedes tener abiertas la otra, bueno, entonces tú llegas aquí y al final te presenta este
ejemplo histórico, en este caso, esto es un sistema intradiliario que vais a ver, para
que sepamos, para hacer lo más real posible el ejemplo, es este sistema que está operando
en canteras, que lleva unos días bastante buenos, la verdad, la verdad que le toca,
este ya pensé que tenía que perder, porque lleva 6, está casi en su récord, 1, 2, 3,
4, 5, 6, 7 seguidos, es casi récord, 7 seguidos acertados para un tendencial puro, es récord,
2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7 seguidos, es rarísimo, tiene que palmar, no puede ser, pero ves,
este ya pensabas que iba a palmar y gana, por eso hay que seguir el sistema siempre,
y a lo mejor te pensas que ya no puede ser y también gana, no, no, es hombre, creo que
son sustos, pero es igual, no estamos aquí por eso, no me despises que tú te vas siempre
de una cosa a la otra, es un sistema tendencial puro y los temas tendenciales puros, pues
tienen, además, tiene aquí dragodrones, intradis fuertes, como este aquí, el susto
debe ser este, no lo veo ahora, aquí, esta vela, realmente tiene un sistema tendencial
puro que intenta dejar correr los beneficios y cortar las pérdidas, pero bueno, pues a
veces les pillan trades muy negativos, pero bueno, este es un sistema que todavía no
está disponible en alquiler, esperamos que no esté pronto, lo tenemos en carteras de
clientes operando, pero no en alquiler en los bloqueos españoles, pero es más por
un tema de tiempo que por otra cosa, esperamos que pronto esté, este chat, uno de ellos,
porque hay varios, uno de los que hemos hecho es este, este está hecho, pone la fecha por
aquí, no, no me acuerdo, pues esto ya lleva meses hecho, eh, no va a poner en ningún
sitio la fecha aquí, ah bueno, muy hábil, vale, esto acabó en octubre, 4 de octubre
del 2013, se hizo este set, desde ahí está una parte auditado y otra ya completamente
operando en live, o sea, todo esto que habéis visto, esto es todo live, esto está operando
no en esta cuenta que está, esta es demo, pero está exactamente igual operando live
en el oro, bueno, entonces aquí que tenemos, que al final nos da el resultado, en este
caso elegimos un fuera de muestra entre 10 y 30, que suelo elegir ese yo, y los runes
ya depende, depende, ¿de qué depende? Depende de los threads que tengamos, y aquí entramos
otra vez en aquella frase que os he dicho antes de que la muestra tiene que ser estadísticamente
significativa, ¿de acuerdo? Lo ideal es que cada rune sea estadísticamente significativo,
¿de acuerdo? Pero aquí sí que somos un poco más laxos que con una sola optimización,
¿por qué? Pues justamente por eso, porque cuando hacemos una sola optimización tenemos
una y aquí tenemos muchas de cada uno de ellos, aquí por poner este tenemos 20% con
15, tienes 15 runes distintos, cada uno de ellos se ha optimizado y se ha aplicado en
otro, pero no solo en este, tienes las pruebas de un montón, de un montón más de runes
distintas, ¿qué quiere decir? Que realmente tienes mucha información sobre la robustez,
o mejor dicho, por no utilizar conceptos confusos, sobre la adaptabilidad del sistema, ¿de acuerdo?
Porque realmente este rune con este no tiene que ver, o sea, este realmente hemos elegido
un período in-sample y out-sample 90%, 10% y le hemos hecho 5 cortes, 5 runs, en cambio
este de aquí, y tiene pass también, lo hemos hecho con un período de 30%, es decir, 70
in-sample, 30% out-sample y lo hemos hecho 25 runs, solo, y ha pasado, es decir, en estos
25 tiene más del 50% for all efficiency el consistency de todo lo que habéis visto,
¿vale? Esto es lo que se ve aquí en el test, que los ha pasado todos, es decir, gana dinero
de media gana más de un 50, más del 50% de los runs de los 25, es decir, al menos 13
ganan dinero de los 25, fuera de muestra todo, claro, contra más runs más difícil porque
lógicamente es más complicado, ninguno de ellos contribuye más del 50 y este tiene
especial mérito porque cuesta, cuesta porque es un tendencial y veréis que hay alguno
que está a punto, mira, a veces aquí tiene 45, 34, porque es normal en un tendencial,
es normal, los tendenciales tienen sistemas con colas muy largas, sistemas de aquello
de que realmente, aquello de la ley del paleto, hasta a veces haces más, realmente el beneficio
total de los sistemas tendenciales viene de muy pocos trades, porque cuando cogen tendencia
ganan muchísimo y luego se pasan mucho tiempo que ahora sí, un poquito, ahora no, a lo
tal, a lo mejor van ganando pero poquito, o perdiendo también, ¿no? Sí, por eso digo
que en esta, yo os confieso, os confieso que hice esta prueba, os confieso que en MSS
hice el workforce optimizer convencido que no lo pasaba, ¿vale? Convencido de que no
lo pasaba, ¿por qué? Porque es un sistema que acierta ya digo 35% de los trades, o sea
es un tendencial puro, vale, un tendencial puro y es muy difícil de que, yo pensaba
que no pasaría la distribución, vale, o sea que habría algún set, de hecho hay alguno
que lo tiene, este yo creo que es por eso que no debe pasar, ¿ves? Por la distribución,
porque el run 2 contribuye más de 50%, disculpe, el porcentaje, bueno, aquí utilizamos de
10 a 30, no, no, pero cuál utilizo quiere decir luego para operar, no, ahora llegaremos,
ahora llegaremos, de momento no hemos hablado nada de operar, esta prueba es una prueba
de estrés, lo que buscamos aquí es que aquí donde pone matrix average ponga pas,
si pone pas estamos contentos, quiere decir que el sistema es un sistema objetivamente
robusto, ¿por qué? Porque hemos conseguido que se adapte a muchas condiciones de cambio
de mercado porque, insisto, este set de aquí, estos 5 run no tiene nada que ver, o sea este
primero es de 2011, 2011 tal, o sea, no tiene nada que ver este con este, claro, porque
al haber 25 imagínate la diferencia, o sea, realmente es muy distinto los períodos de
uno y otro, y en todos ellos ha conseguido demostrar que se adapta, o sea que optimizando
un periodo y aplicando mejor parámetro consigue ganar dinero, consigue todo lo que hemos dicho,
las 5 pruebas, ¿no? Y no tiene un drama mayor de un 40, etcétera, etcétera, o sea todo
eso, ¿no? Entonces lo que primero busco es eso, que es robusto, luego ya tú me preguntas
¿qué parámetros elegirías? Bueno, luego la fijación de parámetros, lo voy a comentar
brevemente porque no tenemos tiempo de profundizar, esto la idea es un poco hablar de 3-station,
o sea, es un... para enseñaros la herramienta y que luego vosotros podáis profundizar
en ella, ¿no? Tenemos pensado en el tiempo hacer ya cosas más de sistemas, más aplicado
a la... a cómo elegirías todos los parámetros de un sistema, bueno, pues podemos hacer
un seminario de eso, ¿no? Pero aquí es más que entendáis la herramienta y que la podáis
utilizar, ¿vale? Luego, por folio maestro, es otra aplicación, sí, la respuesta es
sí, pero no aquí, no en esta. Vale, entonces aquí llegamos a la conclusión que lo pasa,
¿vale? Aquí brevemente ya digo, os comento lo que hay, fijaros que tenéis los datos de
todo, de todos los in-sample que hay, de todos, el periodo de optimización, qué parámetros
he elegido, como veis, pues profit, drawdown, blablá, trades, profit factor, de cada uno
de ellos y también de los de fuera de muestra, de todos, todos, de cada uno de ellos tenéis
los estadísticos principales, abajo tenéis la media, ¿vale? El mayor, el menor, ¿vale?
Y aquí fijaros que en un in-sample ya te da, por ejemplo, un deratio que también es
importante, el post optimisation risk, que es 1,5 veces el drawdown medio que ha obtenido,
aquí el drawdown está aquí, ¿vale? Tiene 12, pues te da 18, ¿qué quiere decir ver
si alguno de ellos ha pasado ese 18? Fijaros que ninguno tiene más de 18, eso te aprueba
más que nos da confianza, ninguno de los hechos ha tenido más de 18 medio drawdown,
es decir, que las previsiones, las previsiones, pues van bien, van bien, porque eso todo esto
es fuera de muestra o al final es como si fuera live, estamos de acuerdo, eso es como
si aquí ese día hubiéramos activado el sistema live, con esos parámetros, ¿no? El beneficio
anualizado, esta es la variable que compara, ves, para obtener el world forward, ves, 100%,
100, 32, 32, se ha ganado lo mismo, el sistema ha ganado en este conjunto que es 15% autosample,
10 runs, en este conjunto tienes 100% world forward de efficiency, y tenemos aquí distintos
ratios de student, desviación estándar, bueno, hay distintos ratos, ¿vale? Y como no, este
a mi me encanta, y tenéis la curva de todo el sistema, de todos esos sets, tenéis el
primero que es in sample, por supuesto, porque claro, el primero tiene que ser in sample,
pero a partir de aquí todo es la curva hecha con los distintos enganches de cada periodo
fuera de muestra, y también todos los straights fuera de muestra, y podéis sacar el performance
report, por defectos todo, pero si queréis solo elegir fuera de muestra, pues lo elegís,
desde 2009-612 lo sacas, no exactamente, me preguntan si se puede, ahora vamos a ver algo
parecido a eso, algo parecido a eso, me preguntan si se puede ver que día de la semana ha ido
mejor el sistema, y bueno, no exactamente en esta prueba, repito que debemos centrarnos
en que esta prueba es una prueba de estrés, ¿de acuerdo? Lo que buscamos es verificar
o tener la mayor probabilidad posible de que el sistema que hemos hecho y que hemos estudiado
para ganar dinero en el futuro, ¿vale? Eso es lo que más probablemente buscamos, acabo
de pronto caer, si, de pronto he tenido un lapsus, digo, he activado el micro en el hangout,
digo, si me doy cuenta que no, bueno, estaba activo, bueno, y esta es la equity preview,
esto es un poco, no es lo que usted me preguntaba, pero aquí sí que puedes ver un conjunto
de parámetros concretos, ¿qué curva tendría? Un conjunto de parámetros, ¿vale? Y aquí
en la distribución puedes ver también análisis de distribución, es que no quiero profundizar
mucho porque si no no voy a llegar a otra cosa, esto como buen sistema tendencial, pues
como os decía, sistema de colas muy largas, ¿vale? Típico sistema tendencial donde tiene,
bueno, luego además puedes hacer pruebas de Monte Carlo, pruebas de Monte Carlo, incluso
la optimización de raíz se puede hacer de Monte Carlo, pero yo personalmente no os lo
recomiendo, ya aquellos que me conocéis, ya sé que Monte Carlo, todo el mundo de los
sistemas hablan de Monte Carlo, Monte Carlo es una herramienta interesante, pero a mí
una herramienta que siempre me da el mismo resultado, pues no me hace falta hacerla porque
ya lo sé que me va a dar, entonces a mí Monte Carlo como yo los backtests que hago
ya son significativos, o sea tienen muchos traits normalmente, o sea realmente es una
muestra estadísticamente significativa, normalmente Monte Carlo empeora un 20, un 30, un 50% de
los resultados, entonces pues bueno, ya más o menos por ahí se mueve, ¿no? Pero bueno,
sí que va a haber a veces sacar este tipo de, o sea Monte Carlo para aplicar, digo Monte
Carlo convencional que la mayoría de gente lo usa un poco para fijar el capital inicial,
para ver el draudón que puedes esperar, para un poco esos criterios, ¿no? Donde sí que
para mí es útil, por ejemplo, para percibir escenarios, ¿no? Para ver en qué porcentaje
hay de que el sistema esté ganando dinero en un año, cosas así, no sé qué me parece,
por ejemplo, puede ser interesante, ¿vale? Bueno, hasta aquí brevemente la explicación
del World Forward Optimizer, ¿vale? Antes os he comentado que también puede servir
para fijar parámetros, ¿vale? Me lo preguntaba usted antes a nivel de parámetros, ¿vale?
Entonces, una ventaja extra que no todo el mundo utiliza, que nosotros donde podemos
utilizar utilizamos y de hecho en nemesis lo estamos utilizando, ¿vale? Este es el clúster
además donde fijamos parámetros, os lo voy a demostrar, creo que el mejor, bueno, aquí,
perdón, muy breve, aquí antes me preguntaba usted si se pueden ver todos los datos, es
aquí, ves, aquí tú tienes el resumen, pero aquí puedes ver el anualizado, de cada de
los sets, el World Forward Efficiency de cada uno, ves, todos, fíjate que hay muchos
con 100 o con 80, 90, muchos, no es uno, claro, si veis solo uno, pero realmente hay una armonía,
hay una armonía en todos los sets, realmente se ve una distribución ordenada, ¿no? Hay
una zona mejor que otra, pero bueno, pero aquí está el 56, que el 56 con 25 runs,
o sea, sigue optimizando cada dos por tres, sin parar, optimizo, pero optimizo, pero esto
es, si haces los periodos de optimización, fíjate que deben ser nada, son 200 días,
200 días optimiza, 90 opera, 200 días optimiza, 90 opera, y con eso ha pasado, es que no me
lo creo ni yo. O sea, con eso ha pasado, haciendo 200 días optimizo, 90 operó, 200 días optimizo,
90 operó, ¿vale? Bueno, el que tú fijes, o sea, tú la muestra, el histórico, tú
lo has marcado aquí en Travestation, o sea, la optimización que hablas aquí, tú en
el histórico que quieras, y luego tú eliges el número de días, pero no por días, sino
por este porcentaje que hemos dicho, ¿no? Tú eliges entre el 5 y el 30%, perdón, entre
el 10 y el 30% fuera de muestra, y con esa variable eliges qué tamaño tiene en el sample
y otro sample de la muestra que tú habías elegido inicialmente en Travestation, o sea,
vamos a iniciar el existo aquí. No, sí, a priori sí, a priori sí, o sea, a priori,
es lo que decíamos antes, ¿no? A priori, tú me dices, hombre, que es más tiempo,
lo que pasa es que un sistema, eso es un sistema que va en 30 minutos, eh, un sistema que va
en velas de 30 minutos, ¿vale? Entonces depende, tú tienes, aquí hay varias teorías y las
dos son varias, depende, lo que te decía, si tú consigues con una optimización no
excesivamente extensa, bueno, cuando no hablo no excesivamente extensa, esta empieza en
2007, ¿vale? Va de 2007 a 2013, bueno, un poco, son años en un 30 minutos, eh, ¿vale?
Estamos hablando de un sistema que va en 30 minutos, ¿vale? Pero el fenómeno salió
a cero desde 2000, bueno, adelante, pruébalo, no, o sea, no hay ningún problema, pasa que
estamos hablando de un 30 minutos, si tú realmente desde ese período consigues adaptar
una ventana, una manera de optimizar y de reoptimizar que al final da resultados como
estamos viendo, tú puedes llegar a la conclusión que por qué no seguir usando ese método,
¿no? O sea, si yo, vamos a suponer, si yo aquí he visto que optimiza, en este caso,
891 días y opera 154, que esto varía porque va por barras, ¿cómo ves, vale? O sea, donde
lo cuadra es en barras y a veces los días pues puede variar por fiestas, por historias,
pero fíjate que más o menos son 891 días, o 29500 barras, optimiza y opera, optimiza
y opera, ¿vale? Si tú llegas a la conclusión que esa manera de reoptimizar es buena, funciona,
tienes ratios que te gustan, ¿por qué no seguir optimizando así? Y es donde entra
esta método que os decía de fijación de parámetros, ¿de acuerdo? Walford automation
se puede utilizar para fijar los parámetros para operar, no aplicaría, no, esto es real,
pero aplicaría en qué, en qué, no me entiendo. Esta optimización empieza en 2007, ¿vale?
Pero si esto lo he hecho yo, o sea, esto lo he hecho yo, lo he hecho mi empresa, o sea,
esto lo hemos hecho los otros. No, no es que, no, es depende, es depende, al final lo que
yo quiero, insisto, es una muestra significativa, una muestra y un sabistica significativa,
en el oro, irse más atrás, en mi opinión, hacemos una reflexión ahora, puede tener
un problema, ¿vale? Porque hemos intentado no irnos, o sea, yo me he ido lo menos atrás
posible en el oro, ¿vale? Lo menos atrás posible, ¿para qué? Para tener muestras significativas.
Fíjate que aquí, no hemos hablado, tienes los stretch in sample, los stretch out of
sample, fíjate que los stretch out of sample aquí de media tienen un 98. En esta prueba
se considera que con 30 son aptos, a mí me parece un poco justo, pero se puede utilizar
porque no es uno, son muchos de 30, ¿vale? Volvemos un poco a la idea de que si tú tuvieras
solo uno de 30, sí que es poco, pero si tienes 10 de 30, claro, que uno realmente esté sobre
optimizado, pero que los 10 lo estén, pues es más difícil, y además de otro set igual,
¿no? Porque hay muchos clusters y realmente si tú ves fail, que ahora te voy a enseñar
uno luego con todo fail, claro, si ves solo dos paths, no, vale, o sea, insisto, lo primero
es que aquí ponga paths, si no pone paths, ni parámetros ni leches en vinagre, o sea,
no vale, no vale este método, entonces no, pero si vemos que hay un paths general, podemos
pensar también en esta situación, porque hemos visto que el sistema se ha adaptado
muy bien, ¿vale? Entonces, entonces yo aquí, ¿por qué en el oro hago eso? Pues en el oro
hago eso, nos va a quedar mal esto por otro día, lo veo, nos va a quedar mal esto por
otro día, ¿por qué hago eso? Pues lo vas a ver enseguida, ¿por qué hago eso? Porque
Nemesis ahora mismo, un sistema que estamos muy atentos y de momento estamos muy contentos,
porque Nemesis está, en mi opinión, como desarrollador de sistemas, en una situación
de riesgo, ¿vale? Al final, cuando uno ya lleva años, pues ya intentas ver por dónde
pueden ir un poco el movimiento de las variables de los parámetros, ¿vale? De hecho, aquellos
que me hayan oído otras veces, digo que yo optimizo mucho, pero no solo para elegir
parámetros, optimizo mucho para ver cómo se mueve el optimizador, ¿de acuerdo? O sea,
cómo se va moviendo con los nuevos datos las zonas de los parámetros, porque eso te
va dando un poco de información de hacia dónde va el sistema, ¿no? Bueno, eso sí
que depende. Nosotros mensualmente intentamos hacerle una pequeña revisión, pero no siempre
implica una optimización masiva con el protocolo de evaluación heavy, ¿vale? Pero sí que
nuevamente miramos. Siempre que una variable de riesgo nos hace récord en live, ya vemos
que... o sea, cualquiera. Traits consecutivos en negativos, drawdown, media perdedora, cinco...
No, no, no, no. Ahora hablo de la operativa en live. No, no, no, no. Ahora no estoy hablando
de what for optimizer. Ahora digo, ¿estamos operando? En general veo que el sistema se
me desvía de lo previsto, in sample, no. Pues valor, ¿no? Al final, en esta cada una
de ellas, pues estos ratios tienes una media, todos ellos se mueven en un parámetro parecido.
No, lo reviso. Lo reviso y vemos. A veces hay que reoptimizar, a veces... Bueno, a veces
depende. A veces se para, a veces no. En principio no se para, pero bueno, tampoco te digo que
no se para. Es decir, depende. Pero en principio no, ¿vale? Entonces, ese sistema va sobre
el oro en 30 minutos. Esto es el oro semanal, pero te lo muestro para que me enseñes. El
oro ha cambiado, claramente, de tendencia a largo plazo. Entonces, si yo cojo mucho
histórico antiguo, voy a coger un periodo de alcista, alcista, alcista, alcista, alcista.
Corro el riesgo de ajustarme en exceso a ese mercado alcista que poco tiene que ver con
el actual, ¿vale? Entonces, me he ido para atrás, pero intentando no ir, intentando,
ya digo, lo menos posible para mantener la muestra estabísticamente significativa.
Para tener bastante histórico real. Y de hecho, ya hemos hecho un set en este mercado,
ya ha ganado dinero. Que quiero por eso decir que está en peligro, porque puede ser, fijaros
ahora aquí, como veis, fijaros que estos parámetros, los últimos sets, fue este el
que elegimos, espérate, lo tengo apuntado, sube, porque ya sé que voy a abrir y tengo
que empezar a matar a todo el mundo y no es plan. A ver, me parece que sí que fue este,
pero fíjate que este último set realmente ha hecho un cambio bastante notable en los
parámetros anteriores. ¿Lo vemos? Y el siguiente se ha parecido al anterior. ¿Veis que habéis
empezado 41-13, 41-12, 37, aquí un variable cambia y además, justamente, me parece que
no le va bien. ¿Ves? O sea, ahí cambia de zona y realmente falla, o sea, realmente la
zona seguía siendo la misma. Bueno, puede pasar, eso es la vida real. Pero aquí fíjate
que pega un cambio, se va a 35-11 y el tercero, fíjate que en ningún caso lo ha dado, ese
11 no había salido nunca, había salido este 10 y había perdido, ¿vale? Aquí sale 35-11,
11, 11, cambia bastante, es decir, que se nota que el sistema está como cambiando y gana,
gana 16 en la media. Y el siguiente que es el life y esto que estáis viendo, esto 35-94010
es esto, este sistema está operando con esos parámetros. ¿Lo veis? 35-94010, este sistema
está operando con esos parámetros. Ya veis que mal no está yendo. O sea, es esto que
habéis visto con todos los traits acertados consecutivos, que es una aberración histórica,
yo creo que puede estar en el récord, te lo digo en serio. Sí, sí, no, no, no, en 7,
ahora mismo no quisiera, a ver, ¿cuánto está cargado? No quisiera decir una cosa por otra,
pero si no hay récord está ahí, o sea, seguro, seguro, o sea, no es, no es, porque aquí no
vienen los winnings, ¿no? Ah, bueno, pero en el performance sí, en el performance sí,
8, falta uno para igualar su récord histórico en life, operando en life, quiere decir que
sigue mostrando que el life va como tiene que ir, bueno, como esperamos que vaya, ¿no?
Este es solo en oro, este sí, pero está previsto trabajarlo en más, pero de momento solo lo
tenemos preparado para, o sea, solo está acabado y operando y tal, pues claro, lleva su tiempo
y tal, pero de momento solo está operando en oro, en 30 minutos, en el GC, este código
que ves, entonces, bueno, lo que íbamos, que no sé qué era, sí, cualquier sistema
tendencial, Roberto, estamos donde estamos, a ver, en principio es un sistema muy tendencial,
pero bueno, eso ahora mismo ya digo no nos interesa mucho, fíjate que los lives también
son muy parecidos a los anteriores y además se ha vuelto a cambiar a 4 y dices, oye, hay
que ver, ¿no? Y este va, este lo ha optimizado hasta octubre y desde ese momento está en
life, claro, no sabemos lo que ha hecho porque va en life, hay que ver cuando acabe el periodo,
cuando acabe el periodo lo diríamos, y cuando acaba el periodo, pues aquí, en OS más 1,
o sea, te da en la optimización que le toca, este sistema le toca optimizar el 11 de marzo
2014, o sea, el 11 de marzo le toca un nuevo run, habrá que calcularlo, si todo sigue
igual y seguimos yendo igual, pues le tocaría en agosto, 16 de agosto, un nuevo run, pero
bueno, lo podemos ir haciendo y cambiar de ventana, si consideramos, pero de momento
ya tú sales a operar con un programa de optimización, está hecho así, o sea, está la ficha,
eso me parece que sí que lo puedo enseñar, a ver, sí, exacto, que está, esa es la ficha
que tenemos de nemesis, además también hemos hecho incluso, o sea, he hecho esta pero también
hemos hecho lo normal, tenemos los dos datos comparados, a un sitio está apuntado a la
optimización, no lo veo aquí, está en el calendario en todo caso, aquí nos ha apuntado,
bueno, pues aquí nos ha apuntado, está en el calendario, entonces, este sistema hemos
fijado los parámetros así, ¿por qué? Porque nos da mucha confianza, un SEMA tendencia
ya ha pasado la prueba así, porque realmente ha demostrado mucha consistencia, porque el
world format es muy alto, por decentes razones, y sobre todo, sí, solo sí, tenemos suficientes
trades fuera de muestra en cada uno de ellos, más de 50, en una serie de runs de 10 runs,
con más de 50 estaría cómodo, fíjate que la media es 98, 98 trades cada set fuera de
muestra, y además, repito, sé que me había acerpesado pero es que es muy importante,
o sea, esta muestra en sí es la que elige parámetros, pero realmente a mí la información
me la dan todos, o sea, lo que le da fuerza a ella misma es que la ha pasado en todos,
vale, es decir, al final yo elijo con una de ellas, o sea, yo me quedo con una, pero
claro, es que la de al lado tampoco estaba mal, es decir, las otras cediscos es que se
ha salido, sí, las dos cediscos quiere decir que ha pasado, cada cedisco es que ha pasado
alguno de ellos con nota especial, es decir, world forward más de 100, o sea, pass es
50, pero si da más de 100 le marca este disco, y en el consistency of profits es más del
80, si le pones estrella es que se ha salido, pero si uno da fail lo marca failed, o sea,
si aquí hubiera salido failed marca failed, o sea, los tiene que pasar todos igual, o
sea, tírales algo, a ver, fíjate que tiene muchas estrellitas también, o sea, además
tiene bastantes estrellitas, entonces, no, la zona verde él elige el centro, en este
caso sí, pero yo no siempre me quedo con la zona verde, no siempre me quedo con la zona
verde, yo luego analizo un poco cada uno de los, cada uno de los, de los parámetros,
no solo el paso, no, Javerto, por favor, a ver si encuentro como el patio colegio empezando
a remartir aquí, avisos, a ver, entonces, yo reviso cada uno de ellos, de acuerdo, cada
uno de ellos, y entonces elijo, porque fíjate que cada uno de ellos te marca una zona,
él calcula el punto donde tiene, está más rodeado, o sea, no calcula el que es el mejor,
sino calcula el que está mejor rodeado, ¿me explico? ¿Por qué? Porque piensa en el error,
¿no? Porque piensa si se desvía, que se desvía a un sitio bueno, ¿no? Vale, entonces sí
que normalmente es una guía, pero no, en este caso que los pasa todos, pues bueno, hubiéramos
podido elegido, pero en este hemos elegido este porque realmente es el que me gusta
más, está más equilibrado en todas, fíjate, no es solo uno, en el beneficio anualizado
es el que más gana, bueno, no, gana más este, pero yo en caso que no haya mucha diferencia
siempre intento irme a más runs, por lo mismo que más trades, ¿no? Vale, siempre
en caso de duda me voy a más runs, ¿vale? Claro, dices, hombre, pero el hecho que a
medida de más runs vaya perdiendo eficacia no es mala señal, no, no, porque en el fondo
te está diciendo, claro, pensá que cuando más runs estás optimizando períodos muy
cortos, o sea, claro, realmente estás, o sea, es más fácil sobreoptimizar, ¿vale?
O sea, es más fácil sobreoptimizar en un histórico de 11.000 barras que en uno de
20.000, pues claro, en este de 25.000, jate, que son 300 días, o este ya al extremo, ¿no?
Es este que hemos dicho solo optimizado 100 días, optimizado 100 días, claro, es más
fácil ahí reoptimizar, o sea, es más fácil que realmente no hayas captado la señal,
¿no? Pero bueno, también nos sirve bien este, fijaros, esto lo miramos, por ejemplo,
ves, para ver este que tiene muchas optimizaciones, ver los últimos que también, fijaros, que
ya ha hecho el cambio, ves, que decía el cambio de parámetros, como han ido, ¿vale?
Los últimos como han ido y este ha perdido, pero no mucho, no podemos considerar que sea
una gran aberración, en el histórico ha perdido bastante más y el anterior gano mucho,
¿vale? Y esto ya es desde 2013, septiembre de 2013, ¿vale? Esto ya es desde septiembre
de 2013, si vamos aquí, es desde aquí, o sea, ya es clarísimamente en el mercado
este, o sea, este mercado podemos decir que está ya metido desde 2011, ¿vale, Loro?
O sea, que ya hay, incluso en estos, jate, ya tienes muchos, ¿vale? Pero sobre todo
los últimos, en este caso, cuando hay menos sets, ¿vale? Porque este tiene muchos, pues
son los últimos, ¿vale? Los últimos ya son fuera de muestra, han sido en el periodo bajista
y aquí tiene más 16, más 26, más 16, menos 3, más, realmente desde aquí ya está en
el periodo bajista, este quizá es el primero que pierde, este puede ser que sea el primero
que pierde, que no capta la señal, puede ser el cambio de mercado, creo que iba por
ahí, sí, exactamente, este coge ya un poco de mercado bajista, es el primero, ves, acaba
en enero de 2012 y viene desde 2009, este acaba por aquí de optimizar, optimiza de
por aquí a aquí y falla, pero ya al siguiente ya no, es que ya le ha cogido la, ya le ha
captado otra vez la señal, ¿vale? Así que el método funciona, es que la reoptimización
consigue captar la señal del mercado, ¿no?, consigue captar de momento, ¿algún día puede
cambiar? Eso sí, o sea, yo siempre digo, los sistemas no son algo estáticos, no son,
no hay que pensar que uno, mucha gente me dice, ah, pon un sistema, te lo pones en la
playa y a vivir, no, no, no, no, no es eso, no es eso, o sea, además hay que trabajar,
hay que seguirlo, o sea, no, no es eso, no es eso, o sea, sería también deseable, pero
no es eso, los sistemas hay que estar encima, no se más pueden dejar de funcionar, hay
que revisarlos, hay que trabajar en ellos, no es, no es coger un sistema de encontrar
que funcione a este, el nemesis y hasta, hola, ya hemos encontrado la gallina de los huevos
de oros, punto, lo pongo a todo el dinero, me vendo la casa, lo pongo todo en este sistema
porque va a ser la bomba, dos años, deja de funcionar, arruinado, no, hay que estar
diversificado, hay que tener varios sistemas, es igual, aunque este ahora mismo es el que
nos parece mejor, tenemos más operando en la cartera, ¿por qué? porque a lo mejor
es el que parece mejor, de hecho, ahora ni que sea brevemente os enseñaré el maestro
y veréis que ese sistema en esa cartera con otro habrá ido muy bien, pero en otras periodos,
¿no? Vale, a ver, sobre World Forward, os enseño
por ejemplo que no, aquí es que no los tengo todos porque es el portátil, es el que uso
más así en casa, digamos que en el despacho está el que hace más estas cosas, pero alguno
más, este es, ah, pero es bruto, esto no vale, este, a ver, ¿esto qué era? Ah, no, me equivocaba,
no hablaba de los cruceros, no, este puede ser, ¿veis? Este es un ejemplo de prueba
fallada, tiene también verdes, pero tiene muchos fails, hay que trabajar más, necesita
mejorarlo, no, este es un sistema que está operando, o sea, este sistema no ha fijado
los parámetros así, este sistema, no, en el SCP, este sistema, concretamente, de una
de las versiones que tenemos, lo puedo decir objetivamente porque he conseguido los datos,
los sistemas habilitados que están en Train Motion, que son 500, es el mejor sistema del
SCP que más beneficio por garantías ganó el año pasado, 49%, este, una versión de
este, bueno, este, o sea, a ver, esto al final viene, claro, a ver, esto viene al final de
una optimización que tú eliges, puede ser, no recuerdo este cuál era, es decir, puede
ser que este no, bueno, no es este, no es este, además, no es este porque este no tiene
el stop entry aún, esta es una versión antigua, pero de todas maneras es una versión, el
sistema ha quedado muy bien, pero aquí tú al final has elegido un periodo determinado,
o sea, tú marcas unas cosas, o sea, el hecho de que te ve la prueba negativa no necesariamente
quiere decir que no es el sistema, a lo mejor tú no has elegido bien el fitness, no has
elegido bien la muestra, bueno, hay que trabajar más, a lo mejor necesitas una muestra mayor,
una muestra más pequeña, depende, vale, depende, este sistema lo pasó claramente,
o sea, Artemisa, Artemisa, ¿cuál ha abierto ahora? No, pero otra vez, es que no los tengo
todos aquí, aquí hay muy pocos, aquí hay muy pocos, no, mira, hay uno de Apolo, este
no es el que ha abierto, no, pero es la misma familia, ah, no, no, este es el B, no, no,
esta es una prueba que hicimos, que quedó descartada, esta es una prueba que hicimos,
esta es una prueba que hicimos de fijar el stop como en el IBS entraría y no, en el
SP no iba, en el SP no iban a haber peor resultados y no lo aplicamos, está operando
la 03, está operando la 03 no a 03B, vale, entonces, bueno, pero es igual, un ejemplo
a título de que puede pasarla o puede no pasarla la prueba, vale, al final es una herramienta
más de estrés que además te permite fijar los, fijar los parámetros en aquellos casos
que te permitan, vale, seguimos, seguimos, bueno, ¿alguna pregunta sobre, sobre el World
Forward Optimizer? Cualquier, no, no, o sea, el programa lo que hace es desear datos, es
un sistema, en forex también, puedes poner sistemas en forex, yo tenemos uno trabajando,
el único tema aquí que tenéis que vigilar es lo que os digo, o sea, esto os he hecho
una resumen importante, la ayuda de World Forward Optimizer también es muy potente,
también está en inglés, pero es muy potente, realmente hay temas a vigilar, lo que decía
el número de 3, o sea, tienen que haber una cierta consistencia, lo que pasa que es verdad
que normalmente si no haces bien el proceso no te lo va a pasar porque es muy difícil
que casualmente pase tantos sets distintos, vale, al final, al final la ventaja de esta
prueba es que lo hacen muchas distintas, entonces puede que luego uno lo pase de chiripa,
pero que pase muchos de chiripa no es fácil, entonces normalmente si no haces el proceso
bien te va del fail, pero lo que te quiero decir es eso, que no siempre que te da fail
quiere decir que no valga el sistema, no llegamos directamente a esa conclusión, que no la
ha pasado la prueba, pero bueno, hay que trabajar más, porque el sistema para operar no es
solo el código, yo sabéis hoy, de hecho, creo que es mi especialidad el backtest, porque
el Roberto se ha especializado más en la programación, yo de siempre incluso cuando
gestiono la Seca Build Club, aquellos que me conozcas, me habéis visto que yo siempre
lo he dicho, a mi la programación no es una de mis especialidades, mi especialidad siempre
ha sido el backtest, al final un sistema para operar es todo, es el código y su backtest,
entonces, o sea, sus parámetros para operar, entonces puede ser que el proceso que hayas
hecho de optimización, la muestra que has elegido, los rangos que has elegido, el tipo
de algoritmo, alguna cosa de la optimización no haya sido el adecuado y necesitas cambiar
algo para que pase esa prueba, pero claro, la tiene que pasar cumpliendo con número
de tres, cumpliendo todo, hay veces que no la pasa, como decía Roberto, que no vale
el sistema. Pues es una buena pregunta, no, creo que no, no, no, no, para nada, lo que
tú tienes que, en 3 Session tienes que tener el tiempo real para operar, nada más, ningún
problema, los datos los cargas igual, los cargas con delay, los datos los cargas, el
histórico lo tienes, o sea, para hacer backtest, sí, sí, sí, en Texas, pero tendrás el anterior
ayer, hoy, claro, no, no, igual, a ver, me preguntan por cómo se puede tener esta herramienta
en 3 Session, sí, sí, o sea, tú para tener la plataforma de 3 Session tienes que cumplir
los requisitos que te exige para operar, para que no te cobre por ella, si no, 10 futuros
al mes, por ejemplo, vale, si tú operas 10 futuros al mes, toda la plataforma es gratis,
punto, y luego para operar tienes que tener tiempo real, pero si tú, para hacer backtest
no, para hacer backtest no tienes que tener tiempo real, o sea, tú puedes hacer un backtest,
tú puedes tener un backtest de futuro BLSP y no tener el mercado BLSP pagado, lo que
no podrás superar luego, el tiempo real, ahora, nada más, ahora al final te enseño
los temas, nada más, lo que hemos comentado, bueno, aquí cuatro cositas, os lo dejo muy
breve y os lo leéis, a ver algo que... todas cosas, en tu ordenador, 3 Session en tu ordenador,
pero nosotros lo ponemos en un servidor, aunque puede ser, ahí hay alguna cosa, se está trabajando
en algo de eso, puede ser que con el tiempo pueda, pero no, no es algo inminente, ¿quién?
ah, no, no, en nuestro caso no, lo tienes tú en tu ordenador o en tu servidor, en sociedad
de que tenemos carteras operando en un servidor que hemos encontrado en Canadá que va muy
bien un ratito y está ahí operando, ya conectamos con el móvil, con el tablet, con el portátil,
con el fijo, con la nevera, con el lavaje, casi ya conectas con todo, tiene scripts,
reinicia, sola, está todo lo más automatizado posible, todo, todo, tiene alertas, eso ya
lo tiene 3 Session, aparte tenemos scripts propios para controlar, es un host normal,
hay empresas de este tipo, pero nosotros como tenemos un programador muy buen profesional
no nos hace falta, sí, sí, pero claro, nosotros pagamos, me parece que pagamos 10 o 15 dólares
por eso y si tú cuantas das, verás que pagas pues 50, 100 dólares por empresas especializadas
en eso, que bueno, está muy bien, es un servicio de esto, pues nosotros pues lo damos, porque
ya pues Roberto lo sabe hacer, él se encarga de eso, pero eso ahora va solo, eso solo se
entra si hay un problema, que no hay problemas y además 3 Session de verdad, una vez, 3
Session solo en algún problema se ha tenido con el net, pero en ordenadores que tú instalas
3 Session de cero para operar, es increíblemente estable, o sea es un software increíblemente
estable, no se cuelga nunca el tiempo de un cliente solo, si el suyo opera solo, bueno
eso es una cuenta, nosotros al final somos un supervisor técnico, eso es una cuenta
que entra a Live, o sea tú cuando entras ahí, luego si puedo dentro de un momento,
no, no, no, no, estamos además en directo, no sé si al entrar enseñar algún dato privado
y estamos transmitiéndonos en directo, entonces tampoco es plan que la policía, si podemos
evitar que venga la policía a buscarlos, pues casi mejor, si puede ser a todos los
señores policías que nos escuchan, tranquilos, tranquilos que no pasa nada, está todo correcto,
David por favor, esto luego lo cortas, gracias, bueno, vamos rápido por favor, lo que os
decía aquí, bueno, esto ya, ah, esto es que creo que es muy interesante, existen, nosotros
todavía no lo hemos hecho, pero existen, existen, me consta que hay algún desarrollador
americano bastante conocido que lo está haciendo, aquellos que hayáis oído hablar
de los Self-Adaptative, son sistemas que hay varias maneras, hay algunos que entrarían,
hay muchas maneras, pero la idea es el sistema que automáticamente cambie de parámetros,
pues oí un webinar bastante, bastante que me gustó mucho la idea, era un sistema que
acá entraría, creo que iban velas de un minuto en el SP y usaban, habían hecho un
World Forward y salían, imagínate, estos diez combinaciones de parámetros, cogían
estas diez combinaciones de parámetros que solo iban haciendo periódicamente, que habían
ido bien en un periodo X, que fuera, porque hablamos un minuto, y luego ellos probaban
desde el premarket hasta media hora de iniciar el mercado que parámetros se habían ido
mejor en ese rato y aplicaban el resto de jornada esos parámetros, automáticamente
en el código, sí, sí, por código, un Self-Adaptative, o sea, él lo elegía y a media jornada tenía
una revisión del tema, a media jornada si había habido un de estos pues podía haber,
pero usaba el, sí, pero usando, no, pero la clave, la clave tiene, a mí eso a priori
si me lo explicas o me gusta, pero así me gusta por una, o sea, ¿dónde me gusta?
porque te lo está haciendo en datos que han pasado en World Forward, o sea, todos esos
sets han ido bien en un momento, me explico o no, entonces él ya te está hablando primero
de un sistema que ha pasado, que ha pasado que es robusto, que ha demostrado que se
ha adaptado en distintos periodos y él elige esos para, o sea, él ha estudiado que viendo
qué tiempo que hemos dicho, más o menos, si un set va bien en ese periodo, pues digamos
tiene capacidad predictiva sobre el resto de jornada, lo ha probado con el World Forward
Optimizer, lo ha salido y por lo tanto tiene datos objetivos para verificarlo, porque esta
prueba es lo que te digo, te permite eso, entonces utiliza esos sets y en tiempo real
va haciendo eso, va probándolo por código implementado y lo va revisando, o sea, cada
continuamente, lo dijo pero no me acuerdo cada cuánto, dijo que continuamente iba reaciendo
el World Forward Optimizer, no sé, cada semana, se llama muy de corto plazo, o sea, cada semana
iba haciendo esto y va aplicando, probando y recuerdo que dijo sets que entraban y salían,
¿no? Habían sets que entraban y salían cada semana de la parrilla de sets, que aquí
digo 10, pero que a lo mejor eran 25, eran más de 10, eran muchos, no me acuerdo, no
quisiera engañarnos, pero eran muchos, eran muchos, a lo mejor eran 25 sets o 20 o los
que fuera, ¿no? Bueno, es una aproximación interesante, es una aproximación interesante,
no me dejo caer ahí porque ahí está, ¿vale? Porfolio, porfolio, ¿vale? Super breve total,
¿vale? Luego intentaremos algún día hablar más de porfolio y porfolio maestro, ¿vale?
Esto que hemos hablado es de World Forward Optimizer, ¿vale? Antes me han preguntado
si se puede mezclar sistemas, sí, no solo se puede, sino que se debe, se debe mezclar
los sistemas, ¿vale? TreSystem tenía otra herramienta de backtest, también en mi opinión
fantástica que se llama porfolio maestro, porfolio maestro es un simulador de carteras
que ahora mismo se abre desde fuera de la plataforma, pero en la 9.5 ya lo han integrado
como una aplicación dentro, es lo mismo que decíamos antes, poco a poco pues va entrando,
¿no? Pero ahora mismo se abre fuera, o sea, hay que hacer login en TreSystem igual, ¿eh?
O sea, no es que se abra, si no tienes usuario no puedes, pero el icono, digamos, está en
el escritorio, hay que abrirlo como una aplicación por separado, ¿vale? Entonces, al final como
os decía, pues tener un porfolio de sistemas es muy recomendable aunque uno tenga un sistema
muy bueno, ¿vale? Porque el sistema muy bueno mañana puede dejar de serlo y eso lamentablemente
no podemos saberlo, podemos intentar minimizar el riesgo, podemos hacer World Forward y está
muy seguros de que es muy sólido, pero el mercado puede cambiar radicalmente, puede
pasar algo que realmente está totalmente imprevisto, algo que nunca había pasado en
el histórico, lo que sea, y se va a dejar de funcionar. Entonces, pues es aquello de
no poner todos los gobos en el mismo cesto, ¿no? Y es una realidad, ¿no? Entonces aquí
pues una de las típicas ventajas, ¿no? Sobre todo mejora el riesgo porque los profit, si
tú sumas un sistema que gana mil y otro que gana mil, ganan dos mil, ¿vale? Bien. Pero
si el primero tiene un drawdown de 500 y el segundo tiene un drawdown de 500, el drawdown
seguramente no va a ser mil. Puede ser incluso que sea 500, eso sería ya el sumo de la perfección
de la descorrelación, pero probablemente pues será 700, será, por decir algo, lo que
sea, ¿no? Es decir, será un drawdown que no será la suma de los dos, por lo tanto
ya es obvio que el ratio de la rentabilidad se suma y el del riesgo no, ¿vale? Por lo
tanto la mejora de la rentabilidad de riesgo es bastante clara, sobre todo de la parte
del riesgo, ¿vale? Y en esa misma línea pues actualizas mucho la equity, ¿no? A veces
incluso puedes perder rendimiento porque pues perder rendimiento quiere decir que si tú
pones solo todo en el sistema del oro que está yendo como un tiro, no, mejor, en teoría
ganaría más, pero también cuando venga el drawdown seguramente perderé más y poniendo
más sistemas puedo suavizar la curva, que también es recomendable, pero sobre todo
para el corazón, ¿vale? Y luego pues aquello de que digo yo, que siempre hay que pensar,
que siempre me habéis ido a hablar, siempre hay que pensar en el riesgo, siempre, cuando
uno opera en el mercado y tendemos la costumbre de pensar demasiado en la rentabilidad. La
rentabilidad está bien, es lo que buscamos, pero tiene que llegar de la mano de controlar
primero el riesgo, ¿vale? Porque si operamos un sistema, si nosotros sacamos ahora este
sistema y creemos mucho en el nemesis, ¿no? Pues a lo mejor venimos aquí seis meses y
nos equivocamos, nos equivocamos con este sistema y no vale. Puede pasar, esto puede
pasar y esto tenemos que tener claro que puede pasar. Por más pruebas que hayamos hecho,
por más robusto que sea, por más lucecitas verdes del PAS, por más, todo lo que queráis
puede pasar. ¿Es más difícil? De acuerdo, es más difícil. Si está todo rojo es más
fácil, vale, estamos de acuerdo, pero puede pasar. Entonces como eso puede pasar hay que
diversificarse, hay que diversificarse. Y aquí he puesto un ejemplo de esto. Esto
es de hace bastantes años, aquello, no sé si conocéis mi trayectoria o no, bueno, aquellos
que no lo sepan, yo presidí un club del 2005 al 2007 que es esto. Estos son datos reales
porque esas curvas son tan poco lineales, porque son de operativa real, las curvas operativas
reales no siempre son tan rectas, ¿no? Esto, no sé si se ve muy bien, si piensa esta leñita
de abajo, esto es un sistema que no ganó, no ganó nunca. Bueno, pues aún así el club
ganó un 85% al final, la cartera, ¿no? Y dices, hombre, ¿y hubiera ganado más sin
ese? Hombre, en valor absoluto sí, pero lo curioso del tema es, y esto aquí no los tengo,
pero los ratios comparativos con los sectoriales se demostraba, o sea realmente ese sistema
se revisó hasta la saciedad, o sea, actualmente ya estaba en el taller, pero siempre aportaba
valor, al final era un sistema que aportaba valor, ¿por qué? Porque estaba muy descorrelacionado
con los otros y realmente iba bien cuando los otros iban bastante mal, entonces llegaba
aportar valor a la cartera, llegaba aportar valor a la cartera, entonces fue un sistema
que siempre se mantuvo porque tenía sentido, a pesar de que no lo parezca en valor absoluto
tenía sentido. ¿Por qué tiene sentido? Porque el mejorar la, porque reducías el
drawdown, reducías el riesgo, mejorar el drawdown tiene varias ventajas, esta es la resumen
de esa que habéis visto, es esta. Tiene varias ventajas, la obvia es que, bueno, pues esto
de que no tienes, que tienes el riesgo más diluido, que no tienes todos los huevos en
el mismo cesto, esta es la obvia, pero hay una segunda más indirecta que es a través
del money management, ¿vale? Reducir el riesgo de cualquier estrategia global, de cualquier
portfolio en general, luego hay que verlo, nos permite ser un poco más agresivos con
la gestión monetaria, ¿vale? O dicho de otra manera, nos permite destinar más parte de
capital a operar y, por lo tanto, desde ese punto de vista, en un caso ideal, puede darse
el caso que un sistema que esté perdiendo dinero, reduzca el drawdown tanto de la cartera,
que la cartera gane más con ese sistema porque puede destinar más capital a operar, no se
me ha explicado. Pues bien, porque yo casi no me he entendido, os lo agradezco. Entonces,
MSA es una muy buena aplicación que también tengo, pero no, no, ni se acerca. No, pero
MSA es muy buena, es muy barata, además, la tenemos, pero porfolio maestro es otra
cosa, porfolio maestro es un monstruo, o sea, ahora vamos a intentar en 5 minutos verlo.
Esto es una imagen de porfolio maestro, a ver, muy breve en porfolio maestro, ¿vale?
Porfolio maestro tú puedes mezclar, primero, tú puedes mezclar distintos sistemas, o sea,
tú mezcas distintos grupos de estrategia y cada grupo de estrategia puede ser una combinación
de una cesta de activos con un sistema con varios, ¿vale? En este caso es solo, por
ejemplo, este, este es este que habéis visto, ¿vale? Némesis, ¿vale? Este es Némesis,
con que símbolo? Con el oro, está ahí. Hay otros, pero tú puedes tener una cesta con
este que va en 4 pares del forex, este mismo va en los 4 pares, por lo tanto tú puedes
mezclar en una cartera infinitas combinaciones de sistemas que pueden estar en distintos
activos, en distintas cestas, son mismas cestas, en distintos time frames, es decir, entre
días, con diarios, con semanales, con lo que te dé la gana, ¿vale? Y por supuesto
en distintos activos, ¿vale? En distintas divisas también. ¿El sistema? Ah, sí, sí,
sí, no claro, ahí la cuenta. No, bueno, esta, esta cartera tiene el riesgo forzado,
pero esta cartera ha salido a operar con 70.000 dólares. La verdad, para mi gusto yo la hubiera
perfilido con 100, esta misma, ¿eh? No, tiene ratios de riesgo asumibles, un poco, un poco,
de verdad, son asumibles, ahora, ahora, no me corres tanto, ahora te lo enseño. A ver,
entonces, bueno, esto al final tiene un backtest, pero ¿qué tiene de particular como muy bien
comentaba aquí Roberto? A ver, cualquier sistema tú, aquí os he dicho el resumen,
tú fijas los parámetros, ¿vale? Fijas el intervalado de ese sistema, los parámetros
que tenga ese sistema, pero tú puedes hacer varias cosas más. Una, aplicar un money management
para cada sistema, que ya puede estar definido en el código como es el caso, aquí hay unas
variables de money management, pero el portfolio tiene implementados varios, de tal manera
que puedes probar de uno a otro rápidamente. Bueno, aquí están todos, o sea, fíjate que
hay fixed fractional, fixed risk, fixed normal, los típicos, pero sobre margen, sobre ATR,
sobre market value, sobre precio, bueno, hay un montón, no vas a profundizar en eso porque
solo con eso te has hecho un webinar de dos horas, solo hablando del money, sí, sí,
quiero decir que imagina que vamos a intentar hacer un vistacito al portfolio de esto para
que veáis la capacidad, luego ya detaremos más adelante a hablar de él, que veáis
su potencia, sencillamente, ¿vale? Luego tú de cada sistema puedes declarar el money
management a cada sistema, ¿vale? Otra variable que nosotros, por ejemplo, todavía no hemos
usado pero que también es bastante interesante es que si tú, imagina que aplicas un sistema
sobre una cartera de 500 acciones, puedes hacerlo, con esa que le haces te le pones acciones
todas. Entonces, el portfolio de esto tiene un sistema de ranking que no deja de ser
otro sistema, un subsistema de selección de valores dentro de una gran cesta, ¿vale?
De ranking, es decir, tú le dices yo quiero que opere solo en los 10 o en el percentil,
en el primer percentil, en el 10% mejores o peores que tiene un determinado dato, RSI
alto, RSI bajo, media de periodos en tal y importado por Excel.
O sea, un criterio que te importe si crees, ¿vale? O sea, criterios de ordenación.
Nosotros, por ejemplo, no hemos usado todavía esto, pero son criterios de ordenación de
valores dentro de la cesta. O sea, tú tienes una cesta, una symbol list y tú quieres que
él utilice, que no quieres le pones no y todos los utiliza todos. Si yo quiero filtraría
otro que quiere decir que no necesariamente, en este caso sí porque solo hay uno, utilizaría
todos los símbolos de la cesta, sino que utilizaría los que cumplieran esos criterios.
Es un sistema de selección, correcto. Sí, es un subsistema de selección de parámetros,
sí, sí. Es un sistema de subselección de símbolos. Sí, sí, sí. No, no, no lo aplica.
Sí, sí, sí, lo puedes, sí, sí, por supuesto, sí, sí, sí. ¿Vale? Entonces, esto no es
sistema, pero luego a cada uno de ellos lo puedes hacer. Luego, además, ahí donde tiene
herramientas muy poderias, esto está muy puesto por los CTAs, ¿vale? Tiene un montón de criterios
de constrictions, ¿vale? Constraints, perdón, restricciones operativas. O sea, tú puedes
fijar, esto yo lo llamo money management a nivel de portfolio, ¿vale? ¿Cómo? Para
money management, sí, para cualquiera que tenga alguna restricción impuesta por la
equity, ¿no? O sea, tú tienes el money management del sistema, pero luego puedes, además, ponerle
reglas, restricciones al portfolio en general. Es decir, el portfolio no puede tener como
mucho 10 posiciones abiertas, 5, 2, bueno. El portfolio como mucho puede ir largo tanto,
se puede apalancar tanto, se puede tal, bueno, distintas, tú las fijas. Porfolio stops,
esto por ejemplo, el otro día, no digo el nombre, había un CTA que me confesó que
lo hacía. Y es discrecional, ¿eh? O sea, que no lo hace por maestro, pero usa exactamente
la misma regla, la que hemos hablado antes. La misma regla, si el portfolio le pierde
más de un 2%, para una semana. No, creo que un mes, no sé si es 100% en el periodo,
pero aquí tú lo puedes elegir, tú puedes poner, no, el portfolio, entero, entero. Esto
de nuevo es aplicable o no, es una opción. Es una opción que tú dices, porfolio stop
2, pues si el portfolio pierde un 2, un 3, un 5, un 10. No, en estas reglas, bueno, una
perdida es un drawdown, ¿no? Es eso, un drawdown. Si llegas a un determinado drawdown, paras,
es eso, pero en porcentaje. Paras qué? Un mes, una semana, un día, lo que tú le digas,
pasa a ese periodo, en la simulación de acá te arrancas. Tú puedes simular eso, a ver
qué pasaría. Puedes elegir la divisa del portfolio, porque pueden haber distintos,
en el global pueden haber cientos de divisas, pero al final dices, bueno, la cuenta en qué
va a estar, originalmente. En dólares, en euros, en peso mexicano, no sé, no sé, no,
creo que no está, todavía. Bueno, dale tiempo. Bueno, entonces, aquí llegas al backtest,
tú preparas todo esto, que hemos ido muy rápido, y llegas a la opción del backtest,
porque también, por supuesto, hay opciones. Por supuesto, comisiones y demás, y cualquier,
o sea, hay una simulación estándar que, sencillamente, con los parámetros que yo
le he fijado, pero luego lo puedo optimizar. Puedo utilizar alguna variable, la que yo
quiera, ¿vale? Cualquiera que esté aquí del sistema, o cualquiera constrain, o cualquiera
esto, o sea, cualquier variable que hemos definido previamente, incluso las de restricción,
la restricción del portfolio, o la de la pérdida del drawdown del portfolio, si quiero también
la puedo optimizar. ¿Qué pruebe? Pues en vez de un 2, probate un 2 y un 4. A ver, ¿dónde
sería mejor parar el portfolio? Bueno, tal vez una manera de ver el portfolio, si a veces
sale a cuenta, es una manera de ver si nos sirve, sale a cuenta aplicar reglas de equity
o no, ¿no? Si antes que aplique reglas de equity, pues mirar si te sale a cuenta o no
en ese portfolio, aplicarlo, sencillamente. Aquí al final lo optimizas, le das, no entro,
ya digo, puedes optimizar, puedes hacer también golf course aquí, pero el clásico, el golf
course, es decir, dejar una parte fuera, ¿no? Pero es igual, no entramos porque, ¿vale?
Y tú al final llegas, que esto al final es muy potente, pero realmente el objetivo es
este, el objetivo es llegar a esto, ¿vale? El objetivo es al final obtener un informe,
obtener un informe de una cartera, déjame mirar lo que he hecho, adiós. No, hombre,
ahora no. No se cuelga, no, hombre, no se cuelga lo que pasa que realmente ahora no
está, o sea, está el hangout abierto, retransmitido online en directo, está haciendo muchas
cosas el pobre, es decir, está haciendo muchas cosas. O sea, claro, cuando estás operando,
eso sí que lo recomienda, mejor tener un ordenador que está quietito, que tenga menos
software instalado, es decir, claro, contra más cosas tenga más problemas, los ordenadores,
pero es como no, cuando lo compras nuevo va como un tiro, cuando llevas un año trabajando
ya todos los ordenadores empiezan a ganar, pues lo mismo, pues es igual, lo mejor es
si tú vas a operar con ese quietito ahí, lo formateas, le pones decisiones, no haces
nada más, y eso va de lujo al principio, de todas maneras no se ha colgado, hemos tenido
suerte. A ver, aquí tienes un sumario, tú has simulado esta cartera, esta cartera es
esta cartera que hemos dicho, que entre ella está el oro, son 10 años, pues ha ganado
450.000, aquí hay un resumen, por ejemplo, me preguntabas ¿qué drawdown ha tenido esta
cartera? 28.000 dólares, esa cartera ha tenido un drawdown de 28.000 dólares, que es un
13% o un 40% sobre el capital inicial, son 70.000 dólares, se lo habrá tenido en principio,
pero en el momento que lo ha tenido, no, un drawdown de 40, en el momento que lo ha tenido
sobre el capital inicial, pero bueno, pues como no tiene monedas, te lo compro, puedes
estimarlo, puedes estimarlo que desgo. Estos datos son, no son todos fuera de monstruo,
pero casi todos, ¿por qué? Porque primero, el sistema del oro está aplicado con unos
parámetros concretos, con los que le tocan ahora, con estos que habéis visto que hemos
elegido para el futuro, pero claro, en todo el histórico anterior, es una manera de penalizarlo
porque realmente no son los que hubiera elegido, con lo cual el oro es todo fuera de monstruo,
porque esos parámetros son los que ha elegido ahora para operar, bueno, el único optimizado
es el que ha optimizado el último set, todo el resto de los 10 años, además son 10,
fíjate que en el oro hemos visto 2007, el oro que es el que más gana es todo fuera
de monstruo, fíjate porque aquí insisto, te vienes en 2010 y tienes todo el oro fuera
de monstruo y el oro es este, bueno, sí que tiene un periodo aquí que pierde, pero bueno,
recupera rápido, fíjate 2005, es este que ves ahora marcado, te quedas ahí quieto,
eso, eso es el oro, ves que incluso, hemos dicho que lo hemos empezado a optimizar en
2007, ¿no? Es aquí, ¿eh? Está en positivo, está en positivo, pero ojo, lo hemos empezado
a optimizar, pero los parámetros que ha elegido ahí no eran esos, recordaros que
han cambiado claramente, esos parámetros se han elegido por aquí, con lo cual es todo
fuera de monstruo el oro, todo fuera de monstruo, Artemisa BLSP es casi la mitad, Apollo es
todo porque es lo mismo, también tiene fijados los parámetros de esta manera, o sea, realmente
hay muchos sistemas, son todo fuera de monstruo, y quiero decir que es un drawdown bastante
realista, barra pesimista, quiero decir, no está optimizado para nada, es un drawdown,
bueno, luego aquí puedes ver lo que han hecho por supuesto todos los sistemas, ha puesto
tener un montón de información de la cartera en global, del portfolio y de todo cada uno
de ellos, ¿no? La lista de los trades de todos, bueno, un montón, ¿no? Y distintos ratios,
bueno, ya digo que hay toda la curva a la cuenta, beneficios periódicos por años, por
ejemplo. No, en este no, en esta versión ya con los tres sets no, no pierdo ninguno,
y luego aquí a nivel de gráficos, pues muy importante, ¿no? Tenés datos aquí, se
ve un poco porque me ha, al conectarme he perdido mucha pantalla, realmente me falta
un montón, tendría que ser más anchos. ¿Él? Sí, sí, ahora lo enseño, pero aquí
veis la equity realizada, pues bueno, una equity bastante estable, insisto y repito
con mucho fuera de muestra, mucho, mucho fuera de muestra, ¿vale? Es una buena equity, aquí
tenemos un drawdown, lógicamente inicio porque no tiene muy management, lo cual lo tiene,
a medida que aumenta capital, el nivel porcentual, claro, ya es irrelevante. No, ahora aquí
no hay, hay, hay, hay, hay, nosotros en futuros por defecto utilizamos el market, pero bueno,
porque venimos a la gestión y nos obliga el apalancamiento un poco, porque es una manera
de controlar el apalancamiento, es el mixed fractional sobre market value, es decir, un
porcentaje, una fracción como market fractional, pero no sobre el riesgo, sino sobre el nominado
del futuro, que es el valor de mercado del futuro, entonces es una manera de controlar
el apalancamiento, porque si no es difícil en futuros, pues si utilizas gatos de riesgo
se te dispara el apalancamiento y no puedes. Bueno, aquí tienes luego puedes ver la curva
de todos, como veíamos, no se ven, no, ganan todos, este es euro dólar, sí, este es un
poco más, bueno, pero es que se opera muy poco, opera muy poco, opera, opera, opera, bueno,
pues tienes un montón de charts, si tuvieras muchos grupos de estrategia, pues podía ver
ahora cada grupo de estrategia separado, aquí en el gráfico, está costando esto ya, vale,
bueno, luego puedes ver, por ejemplo, esto que decía Roberto, es uno que miramos mucho,
por ejemplo, es rolling a 12 meses, que hubiera ganado a 12 meses en cada punto, este es su
primer momento a 12 meses que ganó muy poco, de hecho aquí en la tabla lo tienes, pero
ahí lo ves, peor periodo a 12 meses ganó todos los dólares, no, eso quiere decir
que entrando en cualquier momento, ese mes entrando a 12 meses antes cuando hubieras ganado,
en cualquier momento, 12 meses después, ¿qué ganarías? Vale, o 24, bueno, no, en 12 meses
ha ganado, ha ganado, bueno, ha habido que casi no, pero bueno, tiene el oro que es mucha
tendencia y además pesa mucho el oro, así entre el money management ahí tiene un peso
importante, luego tenemos ya una prueba aquí con money management, he intentado hacerla
antes para que lo vierais, pero bueno, igual han quedado cosas raras, pero bueno, lo pongo
aquí, aquí varían los contratos, porque el Nasdaq como es el más pequeño, realmente
le ha subido contratos, porque esta, el money management como os decía, por market fractional,
por valor de mercado, como el Nasdaq es el que menos valor de mercado tiene, le ha puesto
más contratos, pero bueno, también teniendo en cuenta la equity, teniendo en cuenta por
supuesto la equity, pasa algo aquí, ah no, ya está, ya está, bueno, aquí hay la z
cuenta location, pues puedes ver, pues aquí es el Nasdaq cuando no cambia el otro, realmente
tiene mucha información y los gráficos son todos configurables, exportables, este es
el con el money management y el que más ha tirado del carro es el Nasdaq, el market value
además tiene la ventaja esta de que permite para comparar, nosotros cuando hacemos backtips
de carteras inicial siempre lo usamos, no es este caso, ¿por qué? porque es una manera
de comparar los futuros, porque si no, ¿cómo comparas el futuro del Nasdaq con el futuro
del oro? Claro, el market value es una manera de compararlo, o sea, ¿cómo eliges qué
contratos tiene uno y otro? Ese es uno el nominal, porque realmente el que tiene mayor
valor pues tiene más riesgo también, lógicamente, entonces si no, claro, realmente el Nasdaq
es insignificante a lo del oro, entonces aquí por eso el Nasdaq como ha ido bien, pues ha
empezado, pero déjate que no se empiece así, empezó porque ha ido más, porque como ha
ido ganando pues ha subido, el Nasdaq no estaba el primero, pero ha cogido una buena racha
y como ha ido subiendo la cuenta pues ha ido aumentando el contrato, así que ese es lo
que tiene el money management para eso está, ¿no? No, perfecto, lo aplica, lo lee el código
igual, es el lenguaje lo lee y lo aplica, sí, sí, no hay problema, o sea, tú le pones
no que no aplique ninguno, no, este hecho es así, o sea, este no está aplicado con
el de portfolio maestro, está aplicado en código, sí, sí, cada uno, cada sistema lo aplica
él, tú lo puedes, no, no, creo, la verdad que no creo haberlo probado, no, pero tú
le pones no, lo bueno que tienes es que si tú lo aplicas por él aquí en la columna
te sale, te sale el rato, incluso puedes ver en la tabla de trades te sale la fórmula,
buenísimo, si tú lo aplicas de portfolio maestro tiene una columna última que te sale
el cálculo que ha hecho el money management con la fórmula, no, si viene en el código
no porque es el código, es un easy language, punto, si lo aplica él te viene aquí y te
dice el cálculo que ha hecho, entonces 3x3x4x5, ¿el ratio que él tiene? Sí, sí, es configurable,
o sea, el ratio que él tiene, tú le puedes evitar parámetros luego, todos, sí, todos
y optimizar, si quieres, o sea, cualquier variable es optimizable luego, si quieres,
todas, o sea, tú vas aquí al, sí, es una buena manera, no, pero bueno, pero tú puedes
ser que tengas un ratio que a lo mejor pues es distinto y no lo tiene él, pues lo creas,
lo pones en el código y ya está, o sea, no, pero sí, sí, se puede que cualquier variable
del sistema es optimizable, cualquier variable del sistema es optimizable, a ver, aquí,
estos son las opciones de money management, aquí tienes también parámetros, las de,
las suyas, tú aquí cualquiera de ellas la cambias y cualquiera de estas ahora si yo
la pongo y me voy al portfolio, le voy a backtest, verás que me saldrá, ahora aquí le he elegido
a una, ¿ves? le he elegido a una, voy aquí a money management, ¿ves? me sale la pestaña,
al hacer el backtest portfolio tengo una pestaña que es money management para optimizar esto
si quiero, sí, sí, sí, sí, si quieres sí, pero si estuvieran en el sistema también
podrías porque sería un input de aquí, me explico, aquí son los inputs, esto, money
management vale uno, estos son variables de money management, minimum size, maximum size,
esto yo si quiero optimizado optimizo, o sea, realmente optimizado puedes hacer de las dos
maneras, pero es verdad que a mí también me gusta que lo enseñe maestro, pero bueno,
a lo mejor si tú tienes un rato que lo quieres hacer distinto pues no puedes, pero maestro
tiene que luego te enseña el dato, vale, bueno y tiene algunas cosas más, luego si
haces la optimización salen aquí, aquí puedes ver el trace log, aquí si has hecho, todas
las opciones que has hecho de money management de esto estarían aquí, o sea todas las reglas
que tú has, money management cancelación, o sea trades que no se han podido hacer por
money management, trades que no se han podido hacer por constricción o por ranking, estarían
aquí, podrías ver que trades no se han hecho por las restricciones, o además puedes
hacer correlación, un desmelene, si la correlación entre símbolos ha quedado razonable si, sabes
algo de jesús, a ver vamos a ir abriéndonos y caer porque, dígame perdone, ratio, que
es ratio, ratio de visual, pero que es ratio, pero que es ratio, hay muchos ratios, ratio
visual char, pero eso decía ratio visual char, ratio visual char recovery, Usted trabaja
con visual char, recomiendo que vea el webinar 6, lo vio el webinar 6, vale, bueno esto ves
la matriz de correlaciones, perfecto, se lo agradezco, bueno matriz de correlaciones de
los activos, además puedes hacer algún formular análisis también, aquí ahora bueno, realmente
hay muchos tests una vez hecho al portfolio hacer como veis y no podemos profundizar más
porque es un poco largo, pero es una herramienta realmente muy potente también para mezclar
y para ver que podemos sobre todo esperar de un conjunto de sistemas, un conjunto de
sistemas y cómo pueden mover porque a veces parece una cosa y luego no es tal, es realmente
una herramienta bastante buena. El ratio, bueno, TrayStation tiene TrayStation index,
que es lo que es ratio visual char, pero en el numerador además multiplica los winning
trades, los trades ganadores, es una manera de, es lo mismo rentabilidad riesgo pero al
multiplicarlo por los winning trades digamos que fomentas la tasa de acierto un poco, fomentas,
o sea es rentabilidad riesgo fomentando un poco la tasa de acierto, pero muy parecido,
es lo que le decía, tienen una gran correlación entre ellos, yo lo decía tanto por eso, lo
decía por el inside bar backtesting que Visual no lo tiene, ese es un gran problema, en el
backtesting o sea realmente las barras las simulan y eso, sobre todo hay sistemas que
es crítico, pero es que es otra cosa, es otra cosa, o sea no, luego por ejemplo TrayStation
ajusta el futuro, ajusta el futuro, Visual no ajusta el futuro, la persona que viene
que yo, yo pegué muchos años con Visual, estuve años y años pidiéndoles y llegué
con ellos hasta hablar un histórico del CAC, trabajarlo con ellos porque lo iban a hacer,
no sé qué pasó que al final no lo hicieron, pero tuvieron previsto hace un montón de
años hacerlo, porque ellos lo hacen con acciones, muy bien hecho, o sea ajusta las acciones,
muy bien hecho, sí sí, yo tampoco, bueno pues vamos a intentar a ver si en skype podemos
hacer algo con nuestros amigos, alguna pregunta de maestro de, sí dígame, dígame, cuentas
gestionadas, no, cuentas gestionadas como tal no, porque en ese país no se puede gestionar,
eso es la realidad, otra cosa, no se puede gestionar legalmente, solo se puede gestionar
por una institución de inversión colectiva, nosotros lo que hacemos es desarrollamos carteras
para clientes, por eso como desarrolladores de software lo podemos hacer y les ayudamos
a instalarlo y a colocarlo en un servidor si lo quieren o se la damos a usted para que
usted la opere en su ordenador, si quiere eso ya es decisión, pero la mayoría de gente
pues suele elegir operarlo en la nube, nosotros digamos tenemos una supervisión técnica
de ello, como desarrolladores de software, pero no tocamos, no tomamos decisiones, o
sea, gestionar como tal no gestionamos, si, automático ponemos los sistemas y usted
los supervisa y yo los puedo supervisar técnicamente, pero, o sea, es su cuenta, nosotros somos
un supervisor técnico, no, no se debe, es que no se puede hacer, otra cosa es que la
vida, las fuertes MAM son ilegales en España, si, otra cosa es, yo digo, yo no he dicho
en ningún momento que nadie lo haga, porque mucha gente se salta en los semáforos de
rojo, quiero decir, y es ilegal hacerlo, quiero decir, al final, yo no digo que no se haga,
yo digo que la ley española no permite hacerlo, la ley española no permite hacerlo, la ley
española no solo permite gestionar instituciones de inversión colectiva, lo que pasa es que
los desarrolladores de sistemas tenemos la suerte porque, igual que está TraditMotion,
hay supermercados, todos venden sistemas, eso es totalmente legal, porque en los sistemas
como no tocamos el dinero, realmente, o sea, realmente es un programa que da la orden,
pues somos desarrolladores de software, pero ni tocamos el dinero, ni podemos cobrar por
resultados, que las MAM lo hacen, porque si cobramos por resultados entonces ya sí que
estamos gestionando, eso si yo digo lo que dice la ley española, luego ya cada uno hace
y deshace, pero nosotros lo que hacemos como desarrolladores que somos, desarrollamos sistemas,
nos ponemos a disposición del cliente en algún broker español, normalmente si lo
hacemos en la nube lo hacemos a través de TraditMotion, porque es la plataforma que
nos da más, porque es donde los testeamos, o sea, yo tengo un sistema en el futuro de
TraditMotion o Testion, no me importan los datos, yo el backtesting lo hago siempre
en Testion, porque como backtesting para mí es el mejor, o sea, todas las plataformas
tienen puntos fuertes y no puntos débiles, porque también, por ejemplo, el tema del
64 bits, que es un tema que están ahora mejorando, que no lo tienen todavía, la verdad es que
sí lo tienen, para mí es un punto débil, pero aún así el backtesting para mí es
insuperable. Bueno, como MetaTD está muy de moda en Forex, se usa mucho, los históricos
son muy malos, según me han dicho, yo la tengo aquí instalada, la he usado muy poco,
a mí me han dicho, justamente hoy he estado hablando con un buen amigo que opera con ella
y dice que él los importa porque son un desastre, me ha dicho que él los importa, porque dice
que un backtest ahí no se puede hacer, y que él tiene dudas del backtest también,
no sé, hablábamos entre los dos y le he preguntado si él tenía garantía de decir
que el backtest era bueno, me ha dicho que no lo sabía, la verdad que no lo sé, no
sé, porque yo he visto auténticas, y sí que hay, prefiero no dar nombres, pero realmente
el backtest, claro, es que al final te lo crees, la verdad, yo en Testion me lo creo,
me lo creo, el backtest en Testion, y no el de todas me lo creo, quiero decir que al
final el backtest él lo hace y tú saca un numerito ahí y tú te lo tienes que creer,
quiero decir que al final no deja de ser una estadística, el de MetaTrader, no sé, yo
sé que MetaTrader sale en sistemas muy buenos, yo he visto estadísticas de MetaTrader muy
buenas, sí, supongo que están optimizadas, supongo, pero yo he visto muchas estadísticas
de MetaTrader demasiado buenas, ahora, no sé, no digo que sea, seguramente es el desarrollador
que lo acuerdan demasiado o lo que sea, pero es una plataforma que se tiende a haber estadísticas
muy buenas, seguramente, seguramente, seguramente, sí, sí, sí, sí, es todo probable, no,
no, pero yo donde, no, pero eso puede hacerlo también, no, no, pero eso puedes hacerlo
igual, puedes ponerlos o no, claro, igual, no, no, no, no, yo no digo nada, realmente
la tengo y la he trabajado poco, yo sé gente que lo ha dado a operar y esto que le he
dicho me lo han comentado, pero no lo sé, de verdad, no puedo hablar, yo no he llegado
a operar con MetaTrader, no tengo conocimiento para operar y realmente es como se ve, bueno,
es verdad que MetaTrader hay muchos brokers, precios me preguntabas, ¿qué me preguntabas
de precios antes? No, no, en forex es gratis todo, solo pagas el spread, en forex sí,
pero solo para forex, spread, sí, que es bastante competitiva, un dólar 20 el futuro,
en forex es todo gratis y tienes las mismas herramientas, lo único que es solo para forex,
no vas a poder abrir el futuro de SP, si quieres abrir el futuro de SP tendrás que abrirte
la cuenta de futuro y entonces sí que cumplir los requisitos, pero la plataforma es la misma
en forex y no pagas nada, tienes que abrir la cuenta y poner 2000 dólares para abrir
la cuenta, pero luego no pagas nada, solo que te cobras el spread que va en el, ellos
dicen un 8, yo le he visto un 6, un 6, un 8, está, y los históricos de, a ver, Transition,
bueno, es que solo hablamos en el 6, no sé si usted estuvo en el 6, le recomiendo que
vea el 6 entonces, ah, lo he visto ya, ya hablamos un poco de los datos, realmente Transition
destaca mucho con los datos, las bases de datos están bastante cuidadas, están bastante
cuidadas, sí, yo tengo datos de tic data y los comparo porque tengo datos de tic data,
es que Interactive Blockets en datos no acaba de ser, es que los construye, sí, los filtra,
sí, sí, no, bueno, pues es, en tu utilitas forex contra el 6 yo también no, mira ahora
está un 8 porque tenemos aquí un indicador que nos marca el spread, un 7, ahí lo tienes,
un 7, un 8, un 8, ahora está un 8, un 7, un 6, ¿ves? Menos mala que me ha dado razón,
digo, yo le he visto un 6, es que yo se la voy poniendo un 8, yo le he visto un 6, ahora
está en el horario americano, esto es un indicador que ves que depende de la hora de
cambiar de color y bueno, vamos a ver, lo tenemos, ¿te gusta? Perfecto, para gustos
colores, sí, correcto, y eso diría que es bastante general, todos los que tienen tics
yo creo que sí, yo tengo un histórico hecho con dig data, claro, sí, de acuerdo, pero
qué pasa, ¿por qué no va esto ahora? Cambia la cuenta que no me acuerdo, ahora, no me
ha dicho nada Jesús, pero es que no me ha dicho nada. Bueno, perdonad porque estamos
aquí hablando y yo me acabo de acordar que sigo conectado en directo, ¿ves lo que pasa?
Tenéis que venir, esto va para los entrenadores, tenéis que venir porque lo mejor es la charla,
bueno, y las cervezas, están aquí ahora con unas cervezas, unas copas aquí, sacaron
unos canapés, están sacando aquí un festival, un festival de, no digo más, es como la película
más o menos, ahora ha empezado aquí a circular, yo no la he visto todavía pero me han explicado,
ahora empiezan a entrar las chicas por aquí y no sé cuántas cosas más, en fin, perdonadme
las mujeres que nos estáis escuchando, ya sabéis que los hombres somos primitivos.
Bueno, pues nada, me despido ya de todos vosotros y vosotras, espero, si había alguna ya yo
creo que ya se ha ido con este comentario que he hecho, y nada, pues vamos a intentar
conectar con nuestros amigos de la Trading Week, no sé si lo vamos a conseguir o no,
pero vamos a intentarlo, espero que os haya gustado el webinar y ya sabéis que en cellsandsystemas.com
y en TrayStation.com y en Bolsap.com podéis encontrar información variada y sobre TrayStation,
sobre Cellsandsistemas, si tenéis alguna duda también sobre sistemas o lo que sea,
y el próximo webinar que sería ya el octavo, pues no sé cuándo va a ser, pues supongo
que en un mes o así lo daremos, ¿de acuerdo? En fin, buen fin de semana a todas y a todos
y hasta pronto, chao.